Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 55. Ausgabe, die sich einem, ja einer Mission widmet, die gerade zu Ende geht, die in den letzten Zügen ist. Die Rede ist von dem Weltraumteleskop Planck. Wir hatten hier auch die Schwester-Mission Herrschel schon mal bei Raumzeit intensiv besprochen. Raumzeit 29 mit Micha Schmidt hat sich dem Teil gewidmet, eine Doppelmission, weil hier zwei Teleskope gleichzeitig auf die Reise gegangen sind. Ja, aber das andere, das Planck-Instrument, das haben wir da nicht besprochen und das wird jetzt hier nachgeholt. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Nikolai von Krusenstierlen. Hallo Tim. Ja, wir sind, muss ich noch dazu sagen, wir sind hier am ESOC in Darmstadt beim Raumkontrollzentrum und du bist ja da auch, das ist sozusagen dein Genre hier, also du bist mit in der Missionssteuerung mit dabei.
Genau, also ich habe jetzt leider aufgehört mit Hörschel und Planck, arbeite im Moment bei Sentinel-2, aber habe bis vor einem Monat Hörschel und Planck begleitet, von 2010 an bis vor einem Monat.
Das ist jetzt der Übergang. Also Sentinel-2, das ist der zweite, der da auch gestartet wird im neuen GMS-System. Das haben wir ja auch schon mal intensiv besprochen, aber darum soll es nicht gehen, sondern wir wollen halt noch mal einen Blick werfen auf Planck, wie schon erwähnt. Vorher würde ich aber ganz gerne noch mal einen Blick auf dich werfen. Wie lange bist du schon so im Raumfahrtwesen unterwegs? Wie hast du da den Weg umgebracht?
Also ich habe 1969 als 5-Jähriger gesehen, wie der erste Mensch den Mond betreten hat.
Ach echt? Das hast du noch so in Erinnerung?
Das habe ich sogar noch vor Augen, ja. Und das hat mich angetrieben von da an. Und ich habe dann Physik studiert, ich habe einen Pilotenlizenz gemacht, einen Tauchschein, Amateurfunklizenz gemacht, alles gemacht, was man vielleicht brauchen kann, um Astronaut zu werden. Und habe das aber in der Auseinandersetzung damit verworfen. Ganz komische Geschichte. Ich bin ein Frischluft-Fanatiker. Und das war irgendwann der Showstopper für das.
Aber mit Frischluft ist da nicht so viel da oben.
Da ist nicht, man kann nicht vor die Tür gehen und Frischluft schnappen, das ist nicht. Also das ist eins der Dinge. Aber ich habe das nie aus den Augen verloren, mal mehr oder weniger, und bin eben als Physiker dann natürlich in der Astronomie gelandet. Macht ja sehr viel Sinn. Ich habe Physik studiert und dann mich auf Astronomie spezialisiert. Und dann war netterweise die Diplomarbeit das Entwickeln eines Prozessors für einen Satelliten namens Integral, den auch die ESA geflogen hat. Und das war natürlich ein ziemlich großes Projekt. Und dieser Prozessor heißt HEPI, der fliegt auf Integral nach wie vor, ist ja auch eine ESA-Mission, die noch betrieben wird. Und zwei von denen fliegen da oben rum. Und das bin ich zwar nicht Astronaut geworden, aber mein Mikroprozessor fliegt da oben rum. Und das ist fast genauso gut.
Cool, was ist denn an dem Mikroprozessor so besonders?
Naja, den musste man nur erfinden, weil man Geld sparen musste. Also hätte man genug Geld für die Mission Integral gehabt, hätte man große Antennen zur Verfügung, dann könnte man die kompletten Daten, die da vor Ort produziert werden, auch komplett runterschicken, so wie man das mit Hörschel und Planck macht. Bei Integral ist es so, dass viele der Daten ein Faktor 40 zu viel sind zu der Möglichkeit, sie zum Boden zu schicken. Deswegen muss man Daten an Bord auswählen oder filtern oder integrieren über die Zeit. Und die Computer, die es zu der Zeit gab, die eingebaut worden waren, waren zu langsam, um das zu machen. Und deswegen musste man extra für diese Funktionalität einen Mikroprozess entwickeln, einen sogenannten ASIC, aber das ist einfach fachlaternisch.
Ein applikationsspezifischer, integrierter Schaltkreis.
Und den musste man entwickeln und das ist genau die Aufgabe davon, der integriert über die Zeit zum Beispiel die Daten von einem bestimmten Detektor auf dem sogenannten IBIS-Instrument und diese zeitintegrierten Daten sind dann natürlich viel weniger. So kriegt man den Faktor 40.
Also man nimmt sozusagen einen Teil der Auswertung schon mal vor Ort vor, da muss man nicht so viel schicken.
Ja, das ist wie eine Langzeitaufnahme mit einem Fotoapparat. Dann wird das Bild zwar verrauschter, wenn man wackelt, also es gibt natürlich auch Nachteile, wenn man was weglässt.
Ja, weil wir ja eigentlich immer den rohen Datenstrom haben, weil weißt ja geier, was man da noch so drin findet, das Space Child irgendwo zwischen den Bits.
Also das wäre natürlich toll, man könnte das, aber das war sozusagen eine Randbedingung. Ein Teil der Menge dieser Daten ist natürlich auch Rauschen gewesen und so weiter. Also es ist sehr komplex, jedenfalls, das war, um Geld zu sparen, hat man das sozusagen anders.
Und das hast du sozusagen noch von der Uni weg her gemacht.
Genau, das hab ich an der Uni gemacht. Also so kam ich dann von der…
Welche Uni war das?
Uni Tübingen, am Astronomischen Institut. Und so kam ich dann sozusagen wirklich in Kontakt mit Raumfahrt, weil ich dann ja sowas gebaut hab. Und in diesem, naja, so groß ist die Welt, der Raumfahrt am Ende ja auch nicht. Und ich war dann noch eine Weile, hab danach noch ein Team geleitet, was auch Software geschrieben hat für Integral. War dann öfters auch hier bei der ESORG, war sozusagen während dem Start von Integral ein dreiviertel Jahr sowieso hier bei der ESORG als Mission Specialist. Und hab diese Welt hier kennengelernt. Und leider ist dann sozusagen meine feste Stelle an der Uni doch nicht zustande gekommen, weil die alle weggekürzt wurden. Und dann bin ich sozusagen wegbeworben worden.
Wegintegriert.
Ja, ich bin gefragt worden. Also ich hab mich gar nicht hier richtig...
Die Stellen wurden wegintegriert, ja muss ich sagen. Ja genau.
Und dazu bin ich gefragt worden und ich hab sofort Ja gesagt, weil nicht alle Physiker und Astrophysiker finden Operation spannend. Ich fand das schon immer spannend und hab das als Chance gesehen und genieße das auch jetzt noch jeden Tag. Ich find das richtig klasse.
Was reizt dich daran?
Na ja, ich wollt ja mal Astronaut werden. Also mehr Astronaut kann ich glaube ich nicht mehr werden, als hier Kommandos zu Satelliten zu schicken. Natürlich macht man das ganz anders, als man sich das vorstellt.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch Astronautik. Man lässt nur den Körper unten so.
Also jetzt hab ich ein Gerät, das ich gebaut hab, fliegt da oben. Ich sitze hier und schicke ab und an mal Kommandos. Das klingt für manche vielleicht langweilig. Ich find das richtig spannend.
Das kann man ganz gut nachvollziehen. Das ist ja das Faszinosum von so komplexen Maschinen. Man denkt sich halt vorher so, wenn ich jetzt das tue, müsste er ja eigentlich das machen. Oh guck, hat sogar funktioniert. Und dann eben noch immer diesen besonderen Aspekt, dass man sich eben so viele Fehler da oben nicht leisten kann und nochmal extra drüber nachdenken muss. Das ist ja hier auch schon in einigen Gesprächen immer wieder deutlich geworden. Die Faszination der Raumfahrtsteuerung, auch im Vorfeld, Missionsplanung etc. Die dann auch mal besonders gefragt ist, wenn mal was schief geht. Ich erinnere hier auch an das Gespräch über den XMM-Newton, wo halt dann mal der Satellit eine ganze Woche nicht da war und man dann sozusagen ohne auch nur irgendwas testen kann, sich seine Thesen da erarbeiten muss, wie man es denn jetzt wieder hinkriegt und so.
Also das wollen wir natürlich vermeiden. Und ganz anders als ich es früher selber gedacht habe, das Kommandoschicken ist natürlich nicht so schick, ich denke mein Kommando ist noch schick, sondern es ist alles geplant und getestet und simuliert und steht in Procedures drin und so weiter. Aber das andere, was ich so spannend finde, ich liebe es, habe ich schon immer geliebt, Probleme zu lösen. Ich finde, es gibt nichts besseres auf der Welt, als Probleme zu lösen. Natürlich wünsche ich mir keine, weil ich möchte, dass es dem Mission gut geht. Aber es gibt sie halt. Aber es gibt sie so einmal im Jahr. Pro Mission hat man, glaube ich, irgendetwas ein bisschen Größeres, Komplexeres. Das ist dann das, wo ich denke, oh ja, das ist spannender, kann es nicht mehr werden.
Du bist jetzt hier am ESOG, aber streng genommen bist du ja gar nicht so richtig Teil der ESA selbst. Du bist ja hier an ESA.
Ja, also wie viel? Also die ESA hat, ich weiß gar nicht, sind das 2000 oder 3000 feste ESA-Mitarbeiter? Und die anderen sehen 20.000 außen rum, sind von der sogenannten Industrie. Und da gibt es viele verschiedene Firmen, das verteilt die ESA auch ganz gerecht über die Länder und die Firmen. Und ich gehöre zu einer Firma, die heißt Telespacio Vega Deutschland. Und es gibt aber viele Kollegen, also die allermeisten, die hier arbeiten, sind nicht direkt bei der ESA angesperlt. Und ich bin also auch einer von Leiharbeiter, klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber auf eine Art ist das schon auch so. Aber man merkt es aber im täglichen Leben überhaupt gar nicht. Also das ist völlig egal. Also ich habe das noch nie bemerkt.
Das ist ein Unterschied. Das ist ein Vertragsdetail.
Ja, also da steht halt ein anderer Name auf meinem Badge. Aber das ist eigentlich schon alles.
So, das heißt jetzt bist du hier an der konkreten Raumfahrtsteuerung beschäftigt. Als du dann hierher gekommen bist, dann war welches?
Der Einstieg war integral, da war ich ja eh Spezialist. Das war dann einfach, zumindest von dem Wissen her, was ich aber lernen musste. Also als Physiker und Astrophysiker hatte ich nicht wirklich Ahnung, wie Operations funktionieren. Und habe im Integralteam gelernt, wie man Weltraummissionen betreibt und wie man das auch bei der ESOC macht. Das ist dann auch so ein typisches Physiker-Ding. Dann habe ich mir das angeguckt, habe überlegt, hey, was machen wir denn eigentlich da? Also ich habe mir die Struktur angeguckt und habe angefangen, so ein bisschen zu lesen, habe einen tollen Artikel gefunden. Jetzt muss ich überlegen, in was für einer Zeitschrift. Es war aber eine ganze Zeitschrift voll über Operations, aber da ging es eher um Kernkraftwerke und große Chemiefabriken. Und die haben das ganze Thema beleuchtet und da fand ich spannend, dass die ESA eigentlich oder hier in ESAG, wir machen eigentlich das Beste von beiden, die ich da gesehen habe. Also in den Atomkraftwerken wird alles mit Procedures abgehandelt. Also die gehen davon aus, dass sie 100 Prozent Abdeckung aller möglichen Fälle haben mit Prozeduren.
Also mit vorbereiteten Reaktionsmaßnahmen, wenn X passiert, dann Y.
Genau und die Aufgabe der Operateure ist immer zu feststellen, was ist die Situation, die Signatur und in welcher Reihenfolge und Priorität, wo wir jetzt genau welche Prozeduren ausführen und das heißt aber beim Atomkraftwerk, dass die Prozeduren, wir haben unsere ja auch ausgedruckt, bei uns ist ein Regal oder zwei und bei denen sind es mehrere Regalwände und ich rede von 20, 30, 40 Meter langen Regalwänden. Also das ist diese Philosophie. Und es gibt eine andere Philosophie, die klingt schon fast esoterisch, das gibt es aber wirklich vor allem in familiengeführten Chemieindustrie-Unternehmen, da werden die Ingenieure rausgeschickt und sagen, so einen halben Tag, geh mal zu der Pumpe und hör dir an, wie die sich anhört und mal die und schnuppert dran und also so ein ganz haptiler, sensitiver Umgang damit. Ich habe gedacht, was ist denn das, aber habe das gelesen und die Statistik zeigt, die sind besser im Kontrollieren von Störfällen und so weiter. Also es gibt auch eine Statistik dazu.
Einfach ein Gefühl für die Technik entwickeln im Sinn.
Also zu dem Ingenieur dazu sozusagen die anderen Sinne, die man so hat, sozusagen auch trainieren.
Fällt natürlich bei der Raumfahrt so ein bisschen weg, man kann ja mit seinem Satelliten spazieren.
Natürlich, also das wollen wir auch gar nicht. Nur, wenn ich mir dann mit diesem, als ich das gelesen habe, dann die Struktur angeschaut habe, wie wir das bei der ESOCK machen, wir haben einen Manager, der die Ressourcen managt, ganz wichtig, dass die anderen da den Rücken frei haben. Wir haben die SPACONs, die den täglichen interaktiven Teil machen und unheimlich wichtig sind, damit die Missionen, die Spacecraft-Controllers, die SPACONs, die wirklich, die sind die, die den ganzen Regelbetrieb abhandeln und die sind aber angehalten, wirklich nur die Prozeduren, die für sie geschrieben wurden, zu benutzen. Und selbst wenn sie eine Frage haben, obwohl sie es gestern wussten, sind sie angehalten, den Ingenieur zu fragen. Also sie sollen sozusagen diesen Atomkraftteil, den handeln die ab. Also alles, was normal ist und das ist gut so und das ist ja jeden Tag so. Und dann gibt es die Ingenieure, die im besseren Fall auch wirklich Zeit haben, sich unheimlich tief in die Thematik einzuarbeiten. Unheimlich tief. Also müssen natürlich Reporting und so weiter, aber die sich wirklich spezialisieren können auf ein Fachgebiet. Und wenn man mit denen spricht, also ich kenne inzwischen ja viele, das ist wirklich so, die lieben ihr Instrument und die lieben das Wissen und die, also da geht es weiter als nur reines Fachwissen. Da ist auch eine Faszination dahinter. Und da habe ich gedacht, aber das ist doch super. Wir haben beides, ja. Also wir haben, wir haben auch die Leute, die dann wirklich fasziniert an ihrem Sub-Instrum, an ihrem Instrument, an ihrem Teil sozusagen richtig fasziniert sind. Die können dann auch mal zumindest eine Idee haben. Wir haben zwar keine Procedure dafür, aber das könnte sein. Und dann kann man das testen und so weiter.
Das sind ja dann auch meistens genau die Dinge, die dann eben kritische Missionen dann auch wieder aus dem Dreck ziehen, weil man einfach auf eine Lösung kommt für ein Problem, was so vorher nie mit geschrieben wurde.
Und deswegen denke ich, das macht die ESOC, das macht die richtig.
Du bist dann eine Weile bei Integral noch geblieben, aber dann bist du gewechselt.
Ich bin 2010 gewechselt zu Hörschel und Planck, bin dort zuständig gewesen, nennt sich OBSM-Onboard Software Maintenance. Also die ganzen Instrumente, die ganzen Computer an Bord, die haben ja alle eine Firmware, die haben auch einen Operation Systems. Und diese ganze Software muss verwaltet werden, da müssen Updates aufgefahren werden und so weiter. Und dieses ganze Management, als auch die Durchführung, als auch die Pflege und Hege von dieser Software an Bord, das wird von OBSM gemacht. Und das war die Hauptaufgabe. Ich habe mich aber nebenher auch, also war für Hörschel der Backup, also für die Lage-Regelung zuständig, habe mich auch eingemischt beim sogenannten Mission Planning. Da haben wir was automatisiert und so weiter. Also ich habe mich dann in andere Gebiete mit ein involviert. Aber die Hauptaufgabe war eben dieses OBSM.
Ja, wie schon erwähnt, Hörschel und Planck sind zwei unterschiedliche Weltraumteleskope mit unterschiedlichen Aufgaben, die gemeinsam gestartet wurden, weil sie beide zum selben Zeitpunkt dann einsatzfähig waren und man eben diese Gelegenheit nutzen wollte, mit einem Flug im Prinzip beide abzusetzen, was natürlich dann auch Kosten spart, auch nochmal ganz andere Anforderungen an die Teams natürlich stellt, weil jede Verzögerung verzögert dann eben auch immer das Schwesterprojekt gleich noch mit, aber das hat ja an sich ganz gut funktioniert. Und so sind dann 2009 die beiden dann gemeinsam losgeflogen und irgendwann haben sie sich dann getrennt.
Also sie haben ja mehr Gemeinsamkeiten, also unter anderem, dass es beides Missionen waren, die mit Helium gekühlt werden und wurden. Es waren die ersten beiden Missionen von der ESA, die in L2, also um den L2 herum, den Lagrange Punkt 2. Das ist sozusagen ein spezieller Punkt, den kann man mathematisch ausrechnen im Sonne-Erde-System, an dem man, also ich tu jetzt mal so, als ob man auf den Punkt wäre, das stimmt nachher gar nicht, aber an diesem Punkt kann man sozusagen mit derselben Umlaufzeit um die Sonne fliegen wie die Erde. Und das müsste ja eigentlich langsamer sein. Und das hat was damit zu tun, dass das Ganze sich bewegt. Und das kennt man ja sozusagen, wenn man umkreiselt.
Lagrange Punkte sind halt die Punkte, wo sich eben die Anziehungskräfte der einzelnen Himmelskörper so weit aufheben oder zumindest so einen Sondereffekt haben, dass man da eben einfach so verweilen kann. So kann man dann immer hinter der Erde, gemeinsam mit der Erde um die Sonne herum ziehen. Und das ist dieser L2-Punkt und dementsprechend gibt es natürlich dann noch einen davor. Also wenn man jetzt zwischen Sonne und Erde sein wollen würde, ich glaube, da gibt es keine Missionen, oder?
Doch, doch, doch, viele Sonnenmissionen zur HAU, die Sonnenbeobachtungsmissionen. Die wollen natürlich dahin. Genau. Außer sie gehen noch näher an die Sonne, aber bisher die Sonnenmission, da ist sozusagen der L1 ein guter Punkt.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch die beiden vorne und hinten in der Erdlaufbahn, da könnte man auch noch rumgammeln, da läuft aber nix, oder?
An Missionen ist mir da nichts bekannt, aber es gibt ja sozusagen, das ist insofern halbwegs stabil, dass es immer mal wieder von der Erde auch Begleiter gab, von Gesteinsbrocken, die sich da eine Weile aufhalten, weil das sozusagen auch eine halbwegs stabile Geschichte ist. Und bei anderen Himmelsplaneten kann man das auch beobachten, die sogenannten Trojaner sind das. Und die dann einfach da so mitfliegen. Also das ist sozusagen nicht nur eine Erfindung von den Theoretikern, sondern auch die Natur findet diese Punkte und dann gibt es eben diese Trojaner.
Genau.
Ja, gut, also die beiden Missionen wurden sozusagen von Anfang an übrigens geplant, dass die zusammen fliegen. Und diese Gemeinsamkeiten, dass sie beide eine Umlaufbahn um diesen L2 haben, man bleibt nicht in diesem L2 stehen, das ist nicht, das macht keinen Sinn, aber man hat eine Art Umlaufbahn um diesen L2, die auch riesig groß ist. Also mit einem Durchmesser von anderthalb Millionen Kilometer, das ist also wirklich groß. Und Planck war ein bisschen näher dran, Hörschel war ein bisschen weiter weg. Und das ist also die Gemeinsamkeit, das Kühlen ist das Gemeinsame, es macht also schon, und das ist der gemeinsame Start. Und auch ganz hier bei der ESA, die Teams, wir haben denselben Kontrollraum gehabt, wir haben viele Dinge einfach auch gemeinsam gemacht, uns gegenseitig unterstützt. Also Planck-Leute waren die Backup-Leute, für Hörschel-Leute und umgekehrt. Also das gab viel Interaktion. Es gab schon zwei Teams, aber manchmal war es einfach auch nur ein Team. Also wenn wir Probleme hatten, dann spätestens war es ein Team, weil eben das Wissen auch sehr ähnlich war. Die Plattform ist eh sehr ähnlich gewesen und so weiter. Also das war wichtig und auch gut, weil die Teams beide sehr klein sind. Also man versucht auch immer effizienter, die Satelliten zu betreiben. Und dann war es sehr wichtig und sehr hilfreich, dass die beiden kleinen Teams sich gegenseitig auch unterstützen konnten.
Ziel von Hörschel, es war ja ein Infrarot-Weltraumteleskop, beziehungsweise zum Zeitpunkt dieses Gesprächs. Ist es das auch noch?
Naja, also das Teleskop existiert natürlich noch, aber es wird keine Wissenschaft mehr gemacht mit Hörschel. Am Montag in einer Woche, das ist dann der 19. oder so was, keine Ahnung, werden wir die letzten Kommandos schicken zu Hörschel. Und zwar ein wichtiges Manöver noch, so zu sagen, wir wollen...
17.
Juni. 17. Juni, gut. Wir wollen verhindern, dass Hörschel irgendwann mal wieder zur Erde zurückkommt. Und dann da einschlägt und womöglich Leben gefährdet oder sowas. Die ESA verpflichtet sich ja und aus gutem Grund, Weltraumschrott zu vermeiden und alle möglichen Dinge. Und da wir die ersten Missionen sind, die im L2 geflogen sind, muss man sich auch ordentlich überlegen, was ist eine gute Methode. Wurde viel diskutiert. Das, was wir jetzt machen, finde ich auch selber als die beste aller Methoden, ist, dass wir noch weiter rausgehen, als der L2 und ein sonnensynchrones Orbit einnehmen. Und dann wird Hörschel und Planck werden dann sozusagen weiter um die Sonne kreisen, aber weiter draußen als die Erde. Und ja, es gibt, was weiß ich, in 100, 200, 300 Jahren gibt es minimalste Wahrscheinlichkeiten, dass der vielleicht wieder zurückkommt. Und klar, in 1000 oder 10.000 Jahren wächst dann irgendwann natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Aber für die nächsten paar hundert Jahre ist das so gut wie ausgeschlossen. Aber das sind natürlich auch Störungen und Gravitation hat jetzt die Physik bis heute nicht wirklich verstanden. Das ist ja alles sehr numerisch, wie man sowas rechnen muss. Und deswegen kann man nicht sagen, das ist für die nächsten 10.000 Jahre garantiert so, dass die nicht zur Erde zurückkommen, sondern man kann eben numerisch gute statistische Aussagen darüber betreiben. Und das ist das Beste, was man kriegen kann, auch nach meiner Meinung. Also klar, man hätte vielleicht sozusagen in den Mond stürzen können, aber da stelle ich die Frage, müssen wir da Müll abladen? Ist so eine Frage. Ich finde, und so weiter.
Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip auch schon am Ende, bevor wir richtig angefangen haben. Deswegen möchte ich jetzt nochmal Aufmerksamkeit erstmal auf Planck als solches richten. Planck ist eben kein Infrarot-Teleskop wie Herschel, sondern Planck hat einen ganz anderen Sinn, während Herschel sich eben wirklich so auf die interessanten Stellen im Universum fokussiert hat und so, hier guck mal, da ist doch ganz schön, dass wir mal reingucken und so, und dann eben durch diese massive Kühlung einfach eine Beobachtungsbandbreite hatte, wie es die so vorher nicht gab. Ist die Aufgabe von Planck eine andere und zwar welche?
Also bei Planck, das ist eine Kosmologie-Mission, da geht es darum, wir wollen verstehen, stimmt das mit dem Urknall? Wie ist der Kosmos entstanden? Wie war die erste Zeit des Kosmos? Was ist da passiert? Was sind die wichtigen Parameter? Ist der Kosmos gekrümmt oder nicht? Und wenn er gekrümmt ist, wie stark? Das sind so die Fragen, die hinter Planck stecken. Und was man da zu untersuchen muss, sind verschiedene Dinge. Die Hauptaufgabe von Planck war, und die hat er allen anscheinend, und vor kurzem gab es eine große wissenschaftliche Konferenz, wo die ersten großen Ergebnisse auch präsentiert wurden, mehr als gut auch erfüllen können. Also die Datenlage ist unglaublich gut. Also wir haben ja sozusagen gesagt, wir wollen ein oder zwei Jahre und wir haben jetzt viel mehr Jahre bekommen, also die Daten sind auch wirklich gut. Da guckt man sich etwas an, das nennt sich die kosmische Mikrowellen-Hintergrundstrahlung. Also es geht um Mikrowellen, das kennt man ja aus der Küche. Und was ist das für eine Strahlung? Das Universum war, wenn man an den Urknall glaubt, und das spricht alles dafür, dass das so ist, dieses kanonische Modell in der Kosmologie mit dem Urknall ist sozusagen das Beste, was wir momentan haben und auch schon viele Jahre haben, wenn man daran glaubt, dann nach etwa 300.000 Jahren gibt es einen ganz wichtigen Moment im Universum, nämlich da wurde es durchsichtig das erste Mal.
Also erst hat es angefangen zu knallen. Also man kann ja mal so einen kurzen Abstrakt geben, also keiner weiß so richtig, was davor war, aber irgendwas war mal recht unausgedehnt und die gesamte Masse des Universums befand sich mehr oder weniger in einem Eimer.
Ja, es fing mit Energie an, weil Einstein eh gleich einmal C² wird ja dann Masse usw., aber es war unheimlich viel Energie da und in einem Punkt und das ist auch eine Singularität, also das ist schon mal ganz schwierig zu fassen. Jedenfalls innerhalb der ersten Bruchteile von Sekunden passiert unheimlich viel. Also wir reden von 10 hoch minus 30 Sekunden, also das ist sozusagen am Anfang ganz mini Bruchteile von der Sekunde. Da passiert schon unheimlich viel gleich am Anfang. Auch etwas Besonderes nennt sich Inflation, findet da statt von 10 hoch minus 50 bis 10 hoch minus 30 Sekunden. Also das sind ganz mini Zeiträume und nach, ich glaube, drei Minuten oder so kommt das erste Mal etwas zustande, was so ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat mit unserem täglichen Leben. Da gibt es die ersten Atomkerne, also Wasserstoffkerne oder so, aber erst nach drei Minuten.
Weil vorher alles so energetisch aufgeladen war, dass die Elektronen und so weiter da sind.
Die gab es erst noch gar nicht. Die mussten erst mal entstehen. Also überhaupt mussten Protonen und Neutronen und Elektronen überhaupt entstehen. Also vorher diese ganzen Teilchen, die man aus der Quantentheorie kennt, die mussten auch erst noch entstehen. Also erst mal war es nur Energie und dann so nach und nach entsteht das alles und dehnt sich aus und so weiter. Und erst nach drei Minuten gibt es irgendwas, mit dem man so ein bisschen was anfangen kann als normaler Mensch.
Also nach drei Minuten dann die Atome sozusagen.
Ja, die ersten kleinen, also sozusagen die leichten Atome, Wasserstoff und so weiter. Und dann hat es aber noch mal 300.000 Jahre gedauert, bis dieser Energiematsch aus Materie und es war unheimlich heiß und unheimlich kompakt und so weiter. Und es war, natürlich gab es da schon Licht, aber dieses Licht hatte eine mittlere freie Weglänge von ein paar Zentimetern oder was auch immer und dann war wieder irgendwie Materie und dann gab es wieder eine Interaktion. Also es gab kein freies Licht und erst…
Also das Licht konnte nicht einfach überall irgendwo hin, weil alles war voll mit irgendwas und alles reflektiert sich.
Genau, ein Plasma ist ein, was wir auf der Erde bauen, was so ähnlich ist oder das ist heiß. Da gibt es natürlich auch Strahlung in dem Plasma, das hat aber keine Weglänge, sondern findet sofort wieder Materie und so weiter. Und dann wandelt sich auch Energie in Materium und Materie in Energie und also da passiert einfach viel. Und das hat 300.000 Jahre gedauert und erst dann, nennt man Reionisation, wobei das Re-Quatsch ist, weil vorher gab es das eh noch nicht, aber so wird es trotzdem genannt, wurde das Universum in Anführungsstrichen durchsichtig. Das Licht konnte endlich mal losfliegen und hat nicht ständig, ist nicht ständig in Interaktion mit Masse getreten, trotzdem immer wieder mit irgendwelchen. Aber es gibt immer noch Photonen von diesem Moment, die noch frei fliegen und die sehen wir und die waren natürlich damals unheimlich heiß und die kann man sehen, übrigens früher, als es noch, ich weiß, ich kann mich noch erinnern, irgendwie nachts hat man Fernseh geguckt und irgendwann ist man eingeschlafen und irgendwann wurde man wach, weil das Bild gerauscht hat.
Sendeschluss.
Sendeschluss. Und dieses 10 Prozent von diesem Rauschen ist wirklich diese kosmische Mikrowellen-Hintergrundstrahlung, die man da sieht. Also wenn man das noch mal das Glück hat, dass man Sender ausfällt und nicht 24 Stunden, dann hat man sozusagen seinen eigenen Detektor dafür, wobei man damit leider nicht so viel Wissenschaft machen kann. Aber immerhin, also es ist nichts, was völlig esoterisch ist, diese Hintergrundstrahlung, sondern die gibt es wirklich und die kann man auch mit dem Fernseher messen, wenn man möchte.
War wirklich hypnotisch. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, wenn man da mal so drauf geschaut hat so eine Weile, dann ist man wirklich…
Aber ich war ja eh schon müde.
Bisschen dusselig geworden so dabei, weil es sich eben auch keinerlei Muster in dem Sinne da fand. Rauschen.
Echtes Rauschen. Ja und gut, dieses Rauschen, diese Hintergrundstrahlung, die möchte man sehen und das muss man sich das Weltall als Kugel vorzustellen, ist schon ein bisschen falsch, aber als ein Bild mal, wenn so eine Kugel auf einmal durchsichtig wird, dann gibt es halt in der Kugel überall Punkte, von denen Lichtstrahlen ausgehen, die in alle Richtungen gehen und deswegen können wir jeden Tag immer noch dieses Licht sehen, weil es eben von überall in alle Richtungen ausgestrahlt wurde. Das ist nicht irgendwann vorbei oder so, sondern wir können auch noch die nächsten 10 Jahre oder 100, also das hört nicht auf. Wir werden dieses Licht immer sehen können.
Immer. Man müsste es nicht alles irgendwann mal auch da sein.
Also immer ist ein großes Wort der Abbruchstum echt. Ja, das hängt so ein bisschen ab von den Ergebnissen von Planck. Wie ist denn das mit unserem Universum? Gibt es wirklich die beschleunigte Expansion? Dann sterben wir vielleicht doch den Kältetod, weil das alles so groß wird. Oder das so sieht es momentan einfach aus. Aber wie wird die große Zukunft des Universums aussehen? Und gerade mit Planck-Daten kann man da viele Erkenntnisse darüber legen.
Also um es mal ein bisschen zu versuchen zu fassen, und ich weiß, dass es ein schwer zu fassendes Thema ist. Aber die Urknalltheorie besagt eben so das, was wir eben grob beschrieben haben. Es hatte alles irgendwie einen Anfang, es gab eine Expansion, das Universum wurde immer größer, hat sich in diesem Zuge überhaupt erst mal zu dem gewandelt, wie wir es heute kennen. Dann eben noch mal mit diesem super signifikanten Schritt der Lichtwertung oder der Transparenzwertung sozusagen. Das Licht konnte sich auf einmal ausbreiten. Jetzt dehnt sich das Ganze irgendwie aus. Und ich weiß ja immer nicht, warum dieser Vergleich mit der Kugel so schlecht ist. Sind da zu wenig Dimensionen drin oder warum sollte man sich das so nicht vorstellen dürfen?
Also wenn man sich das nur als Kugel vorstellt, dann kann man ganz viele Dinge natürlich begreifen. Das ist auch gut so. Aber man macht einen kleinen Fehler, weil dann denkt man ja auch immer an den Rand. Und unser Universum hat halt ein endliches Volumen, aber es hat keinen Rand. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Bei einer Kugel, die hat ein endliches Volumen und hat einen Rand. Deswegen ist die Kugel an der Stelle nicht so toll. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel an der Stelle ist einfach, ich hab eben einen Fußball und darauf sitzt eine Ameise. Aber die Ameise hat eine Einschränkung. Normalerweise weiß ich ja die Ameise über vorne, hinten, links und rechts, aber die weiß auch über oben und unten. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber die Ameise im Modell so vorstelle, dass sie nicht über oben und unten weiß, sondern nur vor, zurück, links, rechts und lebt auf der Oberfläche einer Kugel, dann kann sie feststellen, indem sie rumrennt, eine Markierung macht oder so, dass sie auf einer Oberfläche ist, die endlich einen Flächeninhalt hat. Aber sie sieht keinen Rand, weil die kann laufen, wohin sie will. Sie stößt nie an einen Rand. Wenn ich das jetzt transportiere, eine Ebene höher. Das heißt, wir sind in einem dreidimensionalen Raum. Wir können feststellen, dass es ein endliches Volumen gibt, aber wir sehen auch keinen Rand. Da muss man eine Nacht drüber schlafen oder zwei.
Ja, mindestens.
Aber das ist deswegen so. Die Kugel hilft manchmal und manchmal führt sie einen aber auch auf die falsche Fährte, weil man diesen Rand immer mitdenkt. Ich habe es auch nicht von jetzt auf gleich in meine Realität übernommen. Aber das ist sozusagen eine Idee, wie man darauf kommen kann, wenn man sich das mit der Ameise immer forscht.
Aber der Blick nach dem derzeitigen Erkenntnisstand ist schon der, das ganze dehnt sich auch weiterhin aus. Und wie man vor kurzem auch festgestellt hat, vor ein paar Jahren, immer schneller.
Und das ist abstrus.
Und alte Ideen, dass es vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder in sich zusammenfällt, weil die Gravitation insgesamt das alles zusammenzieht, dem ist auch nicht so. Das heißt, es wird irgendwann alles irgendwie viel größer und irgendwann wird es alles dunkel, weil wir nichts mehr sehen und das Licht nicht mehr erreicht.
Genau, wird immer größer. Also das war schon immer spannend, selbst ohne diese Beschleunigung war es ja spannend. Reicht denn die Masse, also was macht die Masse? Ist die Masse so groß, dass sie nachher wieder zu einem Big Crunch kommt? Also das Gegenteil von Big Ben, das ganze Universum geht wieder in einen Punkt zurück oder in einem Klumpen oder was auch immer. Ich mag keine Punkte, weil die so singulär sind, aber geht wieder in ein kleines Gebiet wieder zurück. Oder ist es gerade so, dass sie sich immer ausdehnt, aber sozusagen bis zu einer Maximalgröße? Das wäre sozusagen ein spezieller Wert. Oder dehnt es sich aus und wird immer größer? Das waren aber alles noch Modelle, wo man von der beschleunten Expansion noch gar nicht gesprochen hat. Und jetzt kommt das halt noch dazu. Das Schwierige ist einfach, ich als armer kleiner Physiker habe gedacht, es gibt nur vier Grundkräfte. Und diese beschleunte Expansion, diese dunkle Energie, was ist das? Ich meine, wir Physiker nennen alles dunkel, wo wir keine Ahnung haben. Also dunkle Materie, dunkle Energie. Das heißt eigentlich nur, wir wissen nicht so genau, was es ist. Wir beobachten was, wir brauchen eine Theorie, um diese Beobachtung zu beschreiben. Was ist es? Und ja, es werden Missionen gebaut auf der Erde, konstruiert, um diesen Dingen natürlich nachzugehen. Aber früher war die Welt irgendwie in Ordnung. Da kannte man irgendwie die Materie. Und jetzt auf einmal sind wir die Materie, die wir kennen, die sogenannte baryonische Materie. Das, was wir anfassen können, das, was wir sehen können jede Nacht. Das ist alles baryonische Materie. Das soll jetzt ein oder zwei Prozent sein. Und der Rest ist irgendwas, was wir nicht kennen. Die Beobachtungen sagen das, ja.
Aber es ist immer noch sehr schwer vorzustellen, alles.
Ja, und es gibt auch wirklich keine, es gibt immer bessere Beobachtungen. Also es wird immer fundierter. Also ich habe am Anfang gesagt, ach so ein Quatsch. Aber es wird immer fundierter, die Beobachtungen. Und man kann einfach sagen, hey, ja, das sieht so aus, das dunkle Energie und dunkle Materie, vielleicht gibt es das wirklich. Ich meine, es kann auch sein, es kann auch ganz anders werden. Also sozusagen anstatt dunkle Materie zu postulieren, was die beste Lösung der Datenlage ist, tut es vielleicht auch, indem man den Newton verändert. Also die newtonsche Gesetzgebung wurde ja schon mehrmals verändert. Also mit der Quantenmechanik für ganz klitzekleine Sachen oder mit der Relativitätstheorie für hohe Geschwindigkeiten oder starke Gravitationen. Also das sind ja auch schon Modifikationen. Vielleicht gibt es auch sowas, keine Ahnung, aber da ist es nicht mehr ein Fachgebiet. Also manchmal wird sowas auch anders gelöst.
Aber jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip genau bei dem Punkt. Also Planck ist gebaut worden, um genau in diesem Bereich jetzt mehr Klarheit zu erhalten, als man bisher hatte. Und diese Hintergrundstrahlung, die eben ausgeht von diesem Event, der passiert ist, vermutlich 300.000 Jahre nach, als alles angefangen hat zu knallen. Das Licht fliegt nach wie vor überall rum und lässt sich noch beobachten, auch wenn es natürlich in totaler Konkurrenz steht zu all dem anderen Licht, was sich seitdem entwickelt hat. Denn später kamen ja dann die ganzen Zusammenballungen und die Materie hat sich irgendwie zusammengeflanscht und sich zu Sternen weiterentwickelt und alles strahlt und ist hell. Und diese Hintergrundstrahlung, die super, super, super lange her ist, viele Milliarden Jahre, die...
13.
13 Milliarden Jahre, die... Das ist ja quasi nichts mehr im Vergleich zu dem, was sonst noch alles aufleuchtet, oder?
Vor allem die Temperatur ist anders. Also es war zwar damals unheimlich heiß, aber dadurch, dass sich das wehrt, sich dieses Licht ausgebreitet hat, hat sich das Universum auch weiter ausgedehnt. Und deswegen ist die Temperatur, sozusagen gefallen, auf paar Grad, auf 2,7 oder so ähnlich.
Kelvin?
Also das ist direkt über dem absoluten Nullpunkt. Deswegen muss Planck auch so runtergekühlt werden. Gibt es so eine alte Faustregel, wenn ich was messen will mit einem Messgerät, dann sollte das Messgerät kälter sein als das, was ich messen möchte, weil das sogenannte thermische Rauschen mich sonst stört.
Also diese 2,5 Kelvin ist sozusagen die mittlere Temperatur über das gesamte Universum hinweg.
Naja, in der Hintergrundstrahlung.
Der Hintergrundstrahlung.
Ja, die sind äquivalente Begriffe von Frequenz, sagen wir Mikrowellenstrahlung oder Wellenlänge oder Temperatur. Das sind sozusagen alles Energiebegriffe. Und da kann man das eine nehmen oder das andere. Und um sowas zu messen, also um es gut zu messen und um wenig Fehler zu machen, wenig Grafischen zu haben, muss man eben einen Detektor haben, der kälter ist als das, was ich messen will. Und wenn ich eben Hintergrundstrahlung messen will, dann muss ich noch kälter werden. Das hat man bei Planck hervorragend gelöst durch viele Kältestufen und kam dann sozusagen am Ende bis auf 100 Millikelvin runter. Es gab verschiedene Stufen, eine war bei 2,7 und dann auf 100 Millikelvin. Und wenn die Detektoren so kalt sind und so wenig thermisches Rauschen dann haben, dann ist natürlich die Qualität der Messung unheimlich gut. Das Rauschen, was man da noch hat, liegt an anderen Dingen, aber nicht mehr am thermischen Rauschen. Also das war was ganz Spezielles an Planck und auch dadurch, dass das sozusagen im großen Energiebereich trotzdem gemessen hat, eben nicht nur genau da, wo der Hauptteil der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung liegt, sondern auch da sozusagen kälter und wärmer oder energiereicher und energieärmer, da konnte man viele Fehler rausrechnen oder einfach sehen, ah, das ist ein anderer Effekt oder das ist ein Vordergrundeffekt und so weiter. Und die Kunst an der Planck-Forschung ist was ganz anderes in vielen Bereichen, wie bei Herschel oder XMM. Da guckt man ja auf einzelne Objekte und muss da sehr genau hingucken und sehr präzise hingucken und guckt sich aber praktisch wie mit einer Stecknadel was an und will das so. Und dann guckt man sich aber viele Objekte natürlich an. Und bei Planck will man ja das ganze Universum sehen. Also jedes halbes Jahr hat Planck sozusagen immer das ganze Universum angeguckt.
Genau, also das müssen wir jetzt auch noch mal festhalten. Also es geht ja darum, dieses Hintergrundrauschen, was man schon auf der Erde hat beobachten können, ich weiß nicht, wer hat das noch mal entdeckt? Das war auch so ein Abfallprodukt von...
Ja, die hatten eine Störung gehabt mit so Radioantennen und haben dann irgendwie nicht gewusst, was es ist. Und sind dann drauf gekommen, hey, das ist was Kosmisches. Also es war ja ganz speziell, dass man auf der Erde auf einmal mit Antennen was Kosmisches messen konnte. Also war völlig klar, dass es nicht aus unserer Galaxie kommt usw. Das war ein totaler Krimi damals. Wir können aber was Kosmisches sehen. Was ist das? Wo kommt das her?
Und das war dann im Prinzip auch ein bisschen die Geburtsstunde der Urknalltheorie oder hat die entsprechende Theorie noch weiter befeuert?
Da muss ich jetzt passen.
Das ist auch nicht so wichtig. Auf jeden Fall zu dieser These hat es beigetragen. Und man wusste auch, das ist sozusagen das sichtbarste Überbleibsel dieser Zeit. Das ist das Älteste. Genau, der ältestmögliche Blick ins Universum.
Wir können dann 13 Milliarden Jahre zurückgucken. Das, was wir jetzt sehen, ist Licht, was 13 Milliarden Jahre alt ist.
Eine Zeitmaschine eigentlich, krass.
Wobei natürlich spannend ist, nur von wegen Relativitätstheorie, wenn ich so ein Lichtfoton wäre, mich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewege, für das Foton selber ist in dieser Zeit keine Zeit vergangen.
Null Zeit.
Wieder was zum eine Nacht drüber schlafen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie Licht so Zeit generell so empfindet. Aber vielleicht nochmal der Versuch eines Verständnisses, weil man ja irgendwie denkt, okay, am Anfang war das Universum noch sehr klein. Dann wurde es transparent. Das Foton konnte jetzt irgendwie los schießen. Müsste es jetzt nicht in 13 Milliarden Jahren ausreichend weit gereist sein, dass es sozusagen von uns wegkommt? Wir sind ja eine relativ frühe Galaxie, wenn ich das richtig erinnere. Wir gehören nicht zu den jüngsten Erzeugnissen des Universums. Müsste nicht dieses Licht schon komplett an uns vorbeigerauscht sein?
So viel ist ja auch vorbeigerauscht und hat mit dem bisschen Masse, was es unterwegs gibt, aber es war viel mehr Licht, das an allen Stellen mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig in alle Richtungen ausgesendet wurde. Das war einfach viel Licht zu einem...
Das ganze Universum bestand eigentlich aus Licht.
Es bestand sowieso aus Materie und Licht und das durfte dann das erste Mal frei loslaufen. Und das sieht man immer noch. Und es ist eben so kalt geworden, aufgrund dessen, weil sich das Universum ausgedehnt hat. Und das kann man eben mit den Detektoren von Planck sehr gut messen und kann eben auch feststellen, hey, gehört das wirklich zur Hintergrundstrahlung oder nicht und so weiter. Und es sind zu den anderen Missionen wie WMAP, die das Wesentliche, das Gleiche auch gemacht haben, aber früher, der Sprung in der Güte der Daten ist so groß, dass es momentan zumindest noch nicht mal eine Idee gibt, wie man es besser machen könnte. Es wird bestimmt eine geben. Aber momentan kann man behaupten, es geht nicht besser. Das kann sein, dass man in zehn Jahren oder so wieder was erfindet, dass man es noch besser machen kann.
Okay, also man wollte diese Hintergrundstrahlung jetzt mal richtig einfangen, so gut wie es irgendwie geht. Denn wenn man die dann eben auch und zwar nicht nur so ein bisschen misst und so als solche beobachtet, sondern vor allem eben eine möglichst vollständige Kartografie macht in alle für uns vorstellbaren Dimensionen. Ja, also das ist ein dreidimensionales Bild.
Es sieht einfach so aus, als ob wir von innen auf eine Kugel gucken.
Ja.
Und das Problem, da ist natürlich überall, wo eine Sterne oder unsere eigene Galaxie, die Milchstraße, wenn man irgendwo ist, wo noch nicht so viel Lichtverschmutzung ist, kann man die ja nachts noch sehen. Das ist alles Vordergrund, das stört. Also das muss man alles rausrechnen. Das ist die Kunst bei Planck. Man muss alles, was auf dem Weg dazwischen stören kann, rausrechnen. Damit man nachher diese virtuelle Hohlkugel von innen komplett sehen kann. Das ist natürlich schwierig.
Es ist ein bisschen so, als ob man auf einem Berg sitzt von einer großen Stadt, die mit allen möglichen Lichtern überflutet ist. Und jetzt will man da irgendwo in einem fernen Stadtteil so eine kleine Kerze oder so eine LED-Lampe von einem Gerät beobachten.
Da muss man alles rausrechnen, was Vordergrund ist, damit man das nachher sieht. In den Stellen, wo wir sozusagen aus unserer eigenen Milchstraße rausgucken, ist natürlich viel einfacher. Da erscheinen für uns die nächsten Galaxien ja auch nur als Punkte oder die nächsten ein bisschen größer als Punkte. Aber es ist ja nicht so groß. So viel Materie gibt es ja zum Glück nicht. Da ist es einfach. Da guckt man praktisch wie von diesem selben Berg. Aber da guckt man dann in die Natur und dann sieht man natürlich vielleicht ein Licht in irgendeiner Blockhütte ganz weit hinten. Das sieht man vielleicht schon besser. Aber diese ganzen Vordergrundgeschichten, aber auch natürlich die anderen Galaxien, die weiter weg sind, die möchte man rausrechnen. Also ganz anders wie bei anderen Missionen, wo man gerade die anguckt. Die wollen wir eigentlich erkennen und analysieren und verstehen und dann aber rausrechnen und dann kriegen wir diese Karte. Und das Besondere an der Karte ist, wenn man die ganz grob anguckt, das Besondere ist, dass es ja in jede Richtung, wo ich gucke, hat das genau dieselbe Temperatur, genau dieselbe Frequenz. Das sieht ja alles gleich aus. Das ist schon was Besonderes, weil das bedeutet, dass die Temperatur damals überall gleich war. Und wenn die Temperatur überall gleich war, dann musste das sehr viel miteinander interagiert haben. Denn sonst, warum sollen dann zwei verschiedene Stellen dieselbe Temperatur haben? Aus Zufall vielleicht manche, aber warum denn alle? Also das ist schon wichtig. Das sagt uns einfach, was vorher war. Das musste sehr, konnte nicht riesig groß sein und musste sehr gut miteinander interagieren können. Deswegen lernt man also aufgrund dieser gleichen Temperatur, hat man schon was gelernt darüber, wie das sein musste. Und dann, das richtig spannende ist, aber es gibt Unterschiede, die sind aber klitzeklein, also die gehen im Millikelvin-Bereich.
Reden wir jetzt eigentlich schon über die Ergebnisse von Planck oder reden wir schon über das, was man schon vorher wusste?
Das wusste man schon vorher. Also dass die Temperatur gleich ist, das wusste man vorher und dass es kleine Unterschiede gibt, Fluktuationen, das wusste man auch.
Also im Wesentlichen ist sie gleich, nur gibt es Unterschiede.
Genau, also die sind halt ziemlich klein, die Unterschiede. Und das wusste man mit WMAP auch schon. Aber die Präzise der Vermessung der Unterschiede, wo die sind, also wie klein man sozusagen, wie viele Punkte man von diesen aufgenommen hat, ist natürlich Größenordnung besser wie bei WMAP. Und auch die Temperaturunterschiede konnte man viel vereinbaren.
Das heißt, man musste nicht nur diese schwach leuchtende LED aus dem Großstadtlicht herausfiltern, sondern man musste dann auch noch so genau hinschauen, dass man auch noch die unterschiedliche Helligkeit von zwei LEDs, die an vollständig unterschiedlichen Orten sind, noch miteinander in Bezug setzen konnte.
Und die eigentlich baugleich sind. Und nur die minimalsten Schwankungen, weil die eine vielleicht, keine Ahnung, ein bisschen wärmer ist oder so. Die würde ich dann wieder auch noch sehen können.
Ja, das ist ja eine Herausforderung. Das heißt, jetzt haben sich die Wissenschaftler quasi an dieses Instrument gemacht, um überhaupt erst mal einen Weg zu finden, wie man das beobachten kann. Dazu braucht man ja eine extreme Genauigkeit. Man muss überhaupt erst mal in der Lage sein, zu beobachten. Und du ja gesagt hast, dazu muss man vor allem erst mal sehr kalt sein. Das war ja auch eine Anforderung bei Herrschel. Und ich mich richtig erinnere, wird da Helium mitgeführt, was dann so verdampft und darüber so eine Kühlung erzielt.
Ja, es gibt ja mehrere Stufen. Also das eine, wenn man Helium verdampft, kann man eine Kühlung erzielen. Wenn man aber jetzt quantenmechanisch Helium 3 und Helium 4 mischt und das möchte sich dann entmischen, dann kriegt man das auch noch, sozusagen, das ist was ganz Spezielles. Dadurch kriegt man noch mal eine Kühlung hin, die noch besser ist, das ist aber schon eine quantenmechanische Kühlmaschine, die dann sozusagen eine Atomart nimmt dann die Wärme mit und die andere bleibt kalt. Und über diesen Trick kommt man eben auf diese 100 Millikelvin runter. Also das ist schon einfach Magie fast. Ja, es ist natürlich reine Physik, wird in den Laboratorien gemacht, aber das ist vor 50, 100 Jahren...
Was heißt denn das quantenmechanisch mischen?
Na ja, gut, also wenn ich Helium hab, dann ist das ja ein Atomkern, und den kann ich aber in verschiedenen Qualitäten haben, von wie dieser Atomkern aufgebaut ist. Und dann kann ich diese zwei Sorten nehmen, und wenn die sich wieder entmischen, dann nimmt der eine die Wärme mit, und der andere bleibt kalt. Und das Kalte führ ich dann zu.
Sozusagen einfach verschiedene Arten Helium, die man dann hier auch künstlich hat herstellen müssen, die man dann sozusagen in einen Tank packt und dann durch diese Auseinanderdriften, der ihr eigentlich gar nicht zu uns gehört, macht man nochmal eine extra Kühlung. So, vielleicht mal ein bisschen konkreter jetzt auf dieses Gerät. Also was muss rein und was ist letztlich da zusammengebaut worden? Also was machte Planck aus, um jetzt diese Beobachtung durchführen zu können, außer einer guten Kühlung?
Ja, also sozusagen, es gab zwei Instrumente, sozusagen das LFI, das HFI, das High-Frequency und das Low-Frequency-Instrumente. Und die haben, kann man sich, wenn man Mikrowellenempfänger baut, also das kann man auch im Labor angucken, dann sieht das immer so aus, wie so Hörner, das sind dann die Antennen. Und dann kann man sozusagen, das ist sowas wie Radiotechnik. Also die erste Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahlung hat man ja auch mit Radioantennen gesehen. Also es geht schon so was wie im Radiotechnik. Und dann hat man eben auch für eine ganz bestimmte Frequenz hat man immer optimiert eine bestimmte Antenne gebaut und auch sozusagen einen Sensor, der den empfangen kann. Und die sind dann auch wirklich verschieden groß. Also es ist wirklich mechanisch sichtbar. Diese Hörner haben verschiedene Größen und kann also eben in diesen verschiedenen bestimmten Frequenzen messen. Und macht dann dadurch, dass es auch was spezielles von Planck, der rotiert einmal pro Minute um seine eigene Achse und macht dann praktisch in dieser einen Minute mit seinen, dass es über den Spiegel umgelenkt wird, guckt er praktisch so ein Band an vom Universum. Also wenn man sich hinstellt und um sich herum sozusagen ausgestreckt, dann so ein Band guckt er sich an. Und dadurch, dass sich die Erde ja sozusagen mit Planck und Hörschluss zusammen in einem halben Jahr machen wir eine halbe Drehung um die Sonne. Und wenn man diese Bänder dann addiert, hat man nach einem halben Jahr, hat man dann von innen diese Kugel komplett angeschaut. Oder hat wirklich in jede Richtung geguckt. Obwohl wir immer rotieren, wenn man das macht. Irgendwann nach einem halben Jahr ist das voll.
Und die Tatsache, dass man dabei solche riesigen Wege beschreitet, also im Vergleich zum Universum ist das dann wahrscheinlich zu vernachlässigen. Aber ich meine, man ist ja mal auf der einen Seite der Sonne, mal auf der anderen Seite der Sonne. Man guckt da so quasi immer von woanders.
Na ja, von den Verhältnissen ist das natürlich gar nichts. Das ist natürlich wichtig bei so Missionen wie XMM und Hörschel, wo es dann, wenn man da Zeitanalysen macht, dann ist es natürlich völlig unterschiedlich, wo man ist. Aber wenn man so weit rausguckt, dann ist das sozusagen die Fehler, die man mit anderen Dingen macht, sind so viel größer als die Fehler, die man macht durch die Positionsänderung.
Man schaut ja im Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig sehe, eigentlich permanent immer an das Ende des Universums.
Das sichtbare Ende, man hat das älteste Licht. Wenn man jetzt später guckt, dann ist das Licht halt noch ein bisschen älter.
Aber die eigene Position wird deswegen so unwichtig. Also so ein Kirchturm in fünf Kilometern, den ich mir anschaue, dessen Abbild ändert sich nicht wesentlich, wenn ich jetzt fünf Meter weiter nach links gehe. So muss man sich das wahrscheinlich vorstellen. Also an der Stelle spielt die eigene Position jetzt nicht so eine Rolle. Man müsste schon das halbe Universum durchkreuzen, dann würde es sich durchmischen. Aber so kann man irgendwie betulich um die Sonne herumgezogen werden und es hilft nur noch dabei, weil man im Prinzip immer nur eine einzige Rotationsachse hat. Und die andere Achse ist dann quasi die Drehung um die Sonne. Also das Ding muss sich nur in eine Richtung drehen und der Rest erledigt quasi die Rundumbewegung.
Ja, wir sind sozusagen, weil wir einmal pro Minute dreht sich Planck um die eigene Achse, deswegen sind wir so was wie ein Kreisel. Deswegen sind wir im Raum stabil, weil es gibt ja niemanden, der diese Achse drehen möchte, der von außen da ist. Das heißt, wir haben schon aktiv die ganze Zeit immer mal wieder, also regelmäßig, immer kleine Mini-Manöver geflogen, um diese Achse mitzudrehen, sodass wir praktisch, dass die Achse immer auf die Sonne zeigt. Das ist sozusagen eigentlich der Trick. Wir haben sozusagen die Rotationsachse zeigt zur Sonne, also und da wir im L2 sind im Wesentlichen zur Erde und zur Sonne und haben uns sozusagen aktiv dafür gesorgt, dass diese Achse...
Genau, also irgendwas muss man sich ja orientieren, dann orientiert man sich einfach an der Sonne und dann hat man quasi immer den festen Bezugspunkt und dadurch stellt man sich ja, dass man sich gleichmäßig dreht über den Zeitraum eines Jahres.
Genau, und das ist auch der Grund, warum man in diesen L2 will, weil man dann nämlich Erde und Sonne auf derselben Seite hat und dann braucht man nur ein Hitschschild, weil es geht ja um Kälte bei Hörschel am Planck, man will ja kalt sein und muss also nur in eine Richtung sich gegen diese Hitze wehren und auch wenn man bei 100 Millikelvin ist, ist die Erde ein heißes Eisen und dann muss man das nur in eine Richtung machen. Das macht total Sinn, also Missionen, die man kühlen will, die sollen zu L2.
Das wäre so ein Weltraumkühlschrank, wie die beiden Instrumente, ist auch die Erde ein entflammendes Inferno sozusagen.
Deswegen macht es Sinn, da hinzugehen.
Das heißt, über die Dauer, wie lange ist Herrschel jetzt gelaufen?
Von 2009 bis jetzt.
Drei Jahre.
Nach vier, 13 sind wir.
Also waren das ja auch sozusagen komplette vier Umrundungen der Sonne. Also acht Betrachtungen des Universums.
Hat Planck gemacht.
Hat Planck gemacht, genau.
Also Herrschel hat ja eigentlich nur weggelegt.
Ja klar, ich ziehe mich jetzt auch nur auf Planck. Das heißt, man hat quasi dasselbe achtmal fotografiert und dabei könnte man dann sozusagen auch immer wieder...
Das ist super, weil...
Dasselbe immer wieder neu kalibrieren.
Na ja, also am Anfang, wo noch alle... Also die Kühlung vollständig vorhanden war, weil das Helium wird dann irgendwann verbraucht, ist dann irgendwann verbraucht worden und dann konnten wir mit Helium nicht mehr kühlen. Solange liefen beide Instrumente und solange haben wir wirklich beobachtet und richtige Wissenschaft gemacht. Natürlich wird die immer besser, wenn ich sozusagen noch mal schauen kann und noch mal schauen kann. Und jetzt haben wir achtmal dieses Bild machen können vom gesamten Universum. Und diese Daten werden natürlich immer besser, wenn ich es mehrmals machen kann. Vor allem ist es so, dass auch die Kalibration einfacher wird. Und das Wesentliche am Betreiben von Planck, anders wie Missionen wie XMM, Newton oder Herschel, wo man unheimlich viel rauskitzelt für jede, also möchte man ein Objekt beobachten und dann kitzelt man alles raus an Beobachtung, wie man das machen kann. Und ändert ständig irgendwelche Parameter, um irgendwas zu optimieren. Und das macht total Sinn. Aber bei Planck will man ja, dass das Bild, was ich gemacht habe vor zwei Jahren, vor anderthalb Jahren, vor einem Jahr, vor einem halben Jahr, dass es dieselben Randbedingungen hat, dieselbe Temperatur, alles so gleich wie möglich. Also Planck haben wir ganz anders betrieben. Wir haben so wenig, wir haben uns jedes Mal überlegt, diese Änderung macht vielleicht Sinn, aber wollen wir das wirklich? Oder hat das nicht einen Seiteneffekt? Das haben wir versucht so stabil, also sozusagen, also Herschel und XMM werden auch stabil betrieben. Aber da wird halt auch optimiert. Und dieser Optimierungstrang, den haben wir bei Planck sehr eingeengt, sondern die Optimierung war eine andere. Die war eine Stabilisierung, eine Gleichförmigkeit. Nicht irgendwie das letzte irgendwo rausholen, sondern versuchen, dass es ein halbes Jahr später genau so ist, wie es vor einem halben Jahr war. Das ist also eine ganz andere Philosophie, so einen Satelliten zu betreiben. Und das war eben für Planck wichtig, dass die Messwerte untereinander vergleichbar sind. Von vor einem halben Jahr zu heute, von vor einem Jahr. Und bei anderen Missionen, da ist es wichtig, das Optimum aus einer Beobachtung auszuholen und dann aus der nächsten. Und das kann sein, dass das Optimum für das eine anders ist, wie für das andere.
Ja, aber hier ist Planck sozusagen der fleischgewordene Stillstand. Abgesehen jetzt von der Stillstand oder der fleischgewordene Stillstand, so eine Gesamtstabilität in Relation zu allem anderen. Dann möglichst wenig selber bewegen, selber möglichst thermisch energetische Strahlen, aber dann eben auch in der rein mechanischen Bewegung auch möglichst gleichmäßig zu laufen. Das war das Ziel.
Und das haben wir zum Glück hinbekommen. Also das war wichtig bei Planck, das so zu machen. Und wir haben also, ja, also jetzt kann man es ja sagen, es sind die vielen Jahre einfach vorbei. Wir haben das gut hinbekommen. Also und Herschel hat sein auch gut hinbekommen. Das sind einfach so zwei verschiedene Philosophien. Das hat man auch wirklich gemerkt, wie da gearbeitet wird. Waren zwei Sachen. Beim einen geht es mehr ums Optimieren der einzelnen Beobachtungen und beim anderen ging es mehr ums Optimieren der Gesamtbeobachtung. Das heißt, möglichst wenig Dinge ändern, nur die, die absolut notwendig sind.
Was braucht er denn jetzt, das eigentliche Raumfahrzeug, noch so an Ausstattung? Also es ist ja da gemeinsam mit Herschel hingereist, wurde dann separat ausgesetzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, haben die beide sich voneinander getrennt oder wurden die separat abgesetzt?
Ja, also sozusagen erst wurde Herschel abgesetzt, dann wurde Planck abgesetzt, die flogen auch da sagen erst mal eine Weile hintereinander her. Die sind ja beide auf dem Weg zum L2 gewesen, aber haben natürlich andere Trajektoren genommen, weil sie zu verschiedenen Umlaufbahnen um diesen L2 sollten. Das hatte verschiedene Randbedingungen, was für den einen besser ist und was für den anderen besser ist. Und sind aber mehr oder weniger, es gab schon Zeitunterschiede, waren dann mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig auf sozusagen auf ihren Umlaufbahn und haben dann aber unabhängig voneinander. Natürlich ihre Kreise gezogen und währenddessen. Es ist wirklich sozusagen ein wackelndes, eieriges Ei, das fast Kreis und das sich aber auch zeitlich noch entwickelt. Also es ist relativ einfach, wenn man auf der Erde ist auf der Nachtseise und die Sonne ist wirklich hinter einem, also dann guckt man Richtung L2, also sozusagen Mitternacht gucke ich raus, dann gucke ich zum L2 und wenn ich das tue, dann diesen virtuellen Punkt wird man nie sehen, weil es ist ja ein mathematischer Punkt oder so, aber wenn man sich dann vorstellt, wie die da fliegen, dann würde man sozusagen, wenn man das aufgemalt kriegen würde oder jede Nacht gucken und sich das merken, dann würde man natürlich schon so eine Art Kreisbewegung sehen, wie Hörtel und Planck sich dann, ich glaube im Uhrzeigersinn sogar, beide drehen der eine ein bisschen enger, der andere ein bisschen weiter draußen. Aber wenn man das alles aufzeichnet, dann gibt es sowas ähnliches wie eine Lisa-Jou-Figur für Planck zumindestens. Also das ist sozusagen so ein, da gibt es auch diese tollen Spiele, da hat man Pendel und unten so Sand und dann guckt man das Pendel an und dann gibt es so tolle Muster. So ähnlich kann man sich das vielleicht vorstellen. Und das andere, Hörtel nennt sich dann ein Halo-Orbit, das ist ein bisschen chaotischer. Was wir reell gemacht haben, war folgendes, man muss sich eigentlich nur um eins kümmern. Diese Kreisbewegung, also die grobe Kreisbewegung, die sich auch ändert und wo es natürlich, die bleibt stabil, weil sobald ich zu weit links oder zu weit oben bin, zieht die Sonne und die Erde uns wieder in die Mitte und das ist genau das, was ich brauche für diese Kreisbewegung. Ich werde immer irgendwie in die Mitte gezogen. Das Einzige, was nicht stabil ist, ist der Abstand zur Erde. Ich kann also rausfallen und gehe weiter weg oder ich kann zur Erde zurückfallen. Und das ist das, wo wir regelmäßig einfach beobachtet haben, wo sind wir. Dann kann man mathematisch rechnen, wie wird sich das weiterentwickeln? Das sind sogenannte Mannigfaltigkeiten in der Mathematik, was kompliziert ist, aber wenn man in diesem System rechnet, ist das das mathematische Handwerkzeug. Und dann hat man wirklich statistisch die Flugdynamik ausgerechnet, wenn ich das Manöver fliege, komme ich in diese Mannigfaltigkeit und wie lange ist das stabil? Und dann hat man einfach, ich weiß nicht, hunderte und tausende gerechnet und hat dann das genommen, was am längsten stabil ist im Sinne von der richtigen Abstand. Und dann hat man dieses Manöver geflogen und dann wusste man, jetzt bin ich wieder so und so lang stabil und hat weiter gemessen. Und immer wenn dieser Abstand, weil manchmal ist es zufällig besser gewesen als wir wollten, oder manchmal nicht, und sobald wir gedacht haben, wir sind zu weit aus den Parametern raus, jetzt fliegen wir wieder ein Manöver, dann hat man wieder alle Dinge durchgerechnet, hat das Beste gewählt und hat wieder dieses Manöver geflogen. Und so haben wir diese Stabilität erreicht. In Nympha, im Durchschnitt, war das etwa alle vier bis acht Wochen, haben wir so ein Manöver geflogen, um diese Stabilität zu erreichen.
Aber diese Vorhersicht, Sehbarkeit der tatsächlichen Position war so nicht gegeben, weil da die Einflüsse zu stark sind. Oder warum kann man nicht einfach alles vorher ausrechnen und dann weiß er schon, wann er fliegen muss?
Weil die Störfaktoren so sind, dass ich so oder so Manöver fliegen muss. Also es ist nur stabil in zwei Achsen. Es ist nur stabil sozusagen in der Achse von oben nach unten und von links nach rechts, wenn man von der Erde aus guckt. Aber es ist nicht stabil in dem Abstand.
Warum ist es nicht stabil?
Wenn ich vom L2 ein bisschen näher komme als L2, dann zieht mich die Erde stärker an, als meine Fluchtgeschwindigkeit aufgrund der Rotation ist. Und dann falle ich im Wesentlichen ins Erdesystem. Wo genau ist dann eine andere Frage. Und wenn ich weiter draußen bin, und da bin ich ja zu langsam, und dann fällt man weiter raus. Sobald ich einen kleinen Fehler habe, das ist fast ein chaotisches System, sobald ich einen kleinen Fehler habe, haue ich in die eine oder andere Richtung ab. Ich werde nie von selber zurückkommen. Das heißt, das ist etwas, was ich kontrollieren muss. Und dieses Orbit um diesen L2, dem muss ich nicht kontrollieren. Also den kann ich auch kontrollieren, wenn ich andere Anforderungen habe. Aber das hat dann was mit Eklips und so weiter zu tun. Wann kommen wir in eine Situation, wo die Erde, die Sonne verfinstert oder so? Also es hat dann andere Parameter. Aber wenn wir das außer Acht lassen, könnte man das einfach in Ruhe lassen. Aber den Abstand, den muss man kontrollieren. Das heißt, er wurde regelmäßig gemessen. Und sobald die so vorgegebene Parameter über also dieser Abstand nicht mehr in den Parameterraum gepasst hat, haben wir einfach neu gerechnet, einen Manöver geflogen und wieder dafür gesorgt, dass wir da bleiben. Und wenn wir sobald wir das aufhören würden, würde Hörschel und Planck einfach zur Erde fliegen oder davon weg. Und wir hätten die Kontrolle nicht drüber.
Wie misst denn der Planck das so genau, wo es ist? Ist das per Sternenbeobachtung?
Nein, das kann man gar nicht. Das wird aktiv, wenn wir im Bodenkontakt sind. Wir haben also für Hörschel und Planck im Wesentlichen einmal am Tag drei Stunden Funkkontakt gehabt und in der Zeit neue Kommandos raufgeladen und die Daten runtergeladen. Und in dieser Zeit gab es am Anfang oder am Ende eine spezielle Messung und das ist im Wesentlichen mit dem Funkkanal, den wir sowieso haben, das nennt sich bei uns Ranging. Und dann kann man im Wesentlichen Lichtlaufzeiten messen. Kann man sich das vorstellen. Und so können wir den Abstand messen. Und die Position können wir eh messen.
Man macht einfach so einen Ping und wartet, dass es wieder zurückkommt.
Das ist ein bisschen komplexer als das, aber um sich das vorzustellen, ist das eine Laufzeitmessung. Und das macht man eine Weile und dann kann man eben genau wissen, was ist denn der Abstand von der Bodensstationsantenne zu der Antenne von Planck. Und wir wissen aufgrund, wo ist denn die Bodensstation und wo muss die genau hingucken, dass sozusagen der Empfang optimal ist. Dann wissen wir auch diese Position. Und dann haben wir also X, Y und Abstand, haben dann also die 3D-Position.
Und was muss man dann tun, um diese Bahn dann zu korrigieren? Also welche Antriebe hatte Planck, um sich dann wieder näher in Richtung Erde zu schubsen oder von ihr weg?
Naja, also sozusagen alle unsere Satelliten haben ja so kleine Düsen und die werden mit Hydrazin betrieben. Und dann bei Planck ist es ein bisschen komplizierter, weil wenn man rotiert, ist es natürlich schwierig, solche Manöver zu fliegen, weil kann man nicht einfach eine Düse zünden, weil dann schießt sie unter Umständen in eine komplett falsche Richtung. Das heißt, klar, nur zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten darf eine bestimmte Düse einen Impuls geben und das muss man aber dann öfters machen, weil es, also das wird aber vorher ganz genau ausgerechnet, da sagt man also vorher lieber Planck fliegt das und das Manöver, das macht er dann selber, weil die Onboardsoftware dann schlau genug ist, das dann zu realisieren. Wenn man sich es genauer ankommt, ist das natürlich schwierig, weil dann macht man zwar das Manöver, aber dadurch macht man Fehler dann in dieser Rotation, sogenannte Nutation findet dann statt und dann muss man das korrigieren. Das heißt, Manöver bei uns heißt bei Planck immer, man macht das Manöver, macht ein Korrektur-Manöver und dann tut man auch noch die Nutation dämmen, also sozusagen die Nutation wieder ins richtige Maß bringen. Das heißt, man fliegt eigentlich drei Manöver hintereinander, also erst das, was man eigentlich will, dann die Korrektur und dann die Feinkorrektur.
Und das aber auch in kurzem Abstand.
Und das dauert dann halt einfach, je nachdem, wie groß das Manöver ist, kann das sein, das ist eine halbe Stunde oder das dauert ein, zwei Stunden, das hat man dann halt einfach vorberechnet und dann wird das durchgeführt und danach gemessen, ob es gut war.
Aber ich freu mich gerade, weil diese Eigenrotation, die letzten Endes diese permanente Rundum-Beobachtung ja sicherstellt. Und hast du gesagt, einmal die Minute, das ist ja ein relativ kurzer Zeitraum, wenn man da jetzt so viel Störungen reinbringt, dann versaut man sich ja die ganze Messung damit. Weil das ja sozusagen extrem heilig ist, genau diese Rotationsgeschwindigkeit auch wirklich maximal akkurat beizubehalten.
Ja, an der Geschwindigkeit macht man nicht so viel, aber auch da könnte man natürlich was machen. Aber das sind diese Fehler, von denen ich spare. Also man macht einen Fehler in der Rotation, man macht einen Fehler in der Verkippung von dieser Achse. Aber diese Flugdynamik, das war vorher alles bekannt. Und der Onboard-Computer kann das im Wesentlichen. Außerdem sagt man, machen wir jetzt eine Korrektur, wie die Achse im Raum liegt. Das war das, was wir regelmäßig gemacht haben und geplant. Und das war für uns gar kein richtiges Manöver, weil das war sozusagen Standard, weil wir wollten ja immer, dass die Achse Richtung Sonne zeigt. Aber diese sogenannten Delta-Vs, also da, wo wir sozusagen eine echte Beschleunigung machen und nicht nur unsere Achse im Raum ändern, das waren schon immer besondere Manöver. Und die waren alle vier bis acht Wochen. Und da muss man genau sozusagen das, was man eigentlich will. Und dann die Korrektur sowohl für die Achse, die Achse muss ja nachher wieder stimmen, als auch die Rotation muss stimmen. Also diese ganzen Sachen, die muss man immer nach korrigieren. Aber das ist Standard gewesen.
Keine Raketentechnik.
Ja, natürlich ist genau das Raketentechnik. Aber das gilt ja die alte Regel, alles, was man kann, ist einfach. Und alles, was man noch nicht kann, ist schwierig. Also das war etwas, was wir können.
Ja, jetzt muss man ja im Prinzip, also diese drei Stunden pro Tag, sich Kontakt zum Steuern, aber auch zum Daten abholen. Heißt ja, dass Planck selber die Daten auch zwischenspeichern musste. Wie viele Tage hätte er denn ohne Kontaktdaten, ohne Verlust vorhalten können? Weil das ist ja auch so ein Problem, wenn die Verbindung abreißt.
Also ja, das ist natürlich auch eingeplant. Also geplant war für drei Tage. Wir hätten wahrscheinlich vielleicht auch vier hingekriegt. Also die Menge der Daten, die man an Bord speichern kann, hätte für drei Tage mindestens gereicht. Und das ist auch manchmal einfach auch notwendig gewesen. Also manchmal ist es so und es ist auch gut so, aber die meisten Probleme, die wir haben, sind zum Glück, wenn dann meistens am Boden. Also wir haben zum Glück die wenigsten Probleme sind wirklich mit den Satelliten selber.
Jetzt generell oder bei Planck?
Also zumindest in die Missionen XMM, Integral, Hörschel und Planck, mit denen ich schon geflogen bin. Da war der Großteil der Probleme, wenn irgendwas war, dann hat man am Boden war irgendwas.
Wobei XMM jetzt glaube ich nicht so das beste Beispiel ist, weil da war ja nun wirklich auch mal eine Woche.
Ja gut, es gibt auch diese Probleme, aber wenn man ehrlich ist, also in einem Monat hat man pro Mission sicher irgendwas, wo man erstmal nicht weiß, was es ist. Und so und meistens stellt sich dann aber raus, es ist irgendwas am Boden. Und man ärgert sich darüber, dass es am Boden ist, weil man ärgert sich natürlich, warum muss das sein? Aber eigentlich muss man froh sein, dass es nichts auf dem Satelliten ist.
Ja, aber dann wird es halt knifflig.
Dann wird es eben noch kniffliger und dann kann man das aber auch lösen und dann ist es auch gut.
Genau, aber man muss ja auch sicherstellen, dass die Daten auch korrekt ankommen, weil Planck sie ja dann auch wieder löscht. Also das hat jetzt die ganze Zeit gut funktioniert. Wie stellt man das sicher?
Also es gibt verschiedene Methoden, natürlich das sicherzustellen. Das eine ist, dass wir einfach jedes Mal, wenn wir die Daten runtergeladen haben, danach eine sogenannte Datenkonsolidation gemacht haben. Das war bei Hörschel und Planck das gleiche. Und einfach fest geprüft haben, sind die Daten richtig. Und wenn dem nicht so war, hatten wir eben die Möglichkeit, weil eben dieser drei Tage zyklischer Speicher, die Daten waren nicht gelöscht, die werden nur dann überschrieben, wenn sozusagen neue Daten dazukommen. Und das ging praktisch zyklisch, also wie im Kreis. Und dann halt die ältesten werden immer überschrieben. Das heißt, man hat auch mindestens zwei Tage Zeit, irgendwas, was doch nicht am Boden angekommen ist, nochmal nachträglich sich zu holen. Was wir zusätzlich gemacht haben bei Hörschel und Planck, war, dass wir die Daten auch abgesichert haben mit einer Quersumme sozusagen, mit einem sogenannten CAC. Mit einer Prüfsumme. Das ist optional, das muss man nicht machen. Auf der Ebene von Paketebene. Also ein Paket ist immer sozusagen wie so ein Datenpaket. Und da drin sind dann diese Daten. Und das haben wir halt bei Hörschel und Planck gemacht.
Ist das nicht üblich?
Das ist sozusagen, es gibt ja ein Standard, der sogenannte PUS-Standard, Packet Utilization Standard, wie die ESA die Datenpakete, sowas wie im Internet, hin und her schickt.
Also jedes IP-Paket hat ja so eine Prüfung.
Genau. Und da gibt es diese CAC schon auf anderen Ebenen, also auf den tieferen Ebenen von der Kommunikation, aber nicht auf dieser hohen Ebene von wissenschaftlichen Daten, sondern erst die werden dann bei allen anderen Missionen auch verpackt und kommen dann in irgendwelche Frames und so weiter. Und auf der Ebene gibt es diese, grundsätzlich gibt es diese Quersumme oder CACs. Aber auf Paketebene gibt es das bei anderen Missionen nicht, obwohl das möglich ist. Also es ist ein Teil dieses Standards, aber das ist ein optionaler Teil. Und das haben wir bei Hörschl und Planck verwendet und haben auch jahrelang nie ein Problem gesehen und wurden dann aber einmal gefragt von ASTEC, das ist sozusagen der Teil der ESA in Holland, wunderschön, direkt am Meer, wo die Satelliten zusammengebaut und getestet werden, bevor sie dann endlich gestartet werden. Und da gibt es unheimlich, da arbeiten 1000 von Leuten und die planen natürlich auch mit den neuen Missionen. Und da wurden wir vor anderthalb Jahren mal gefragt per E-Mail, ja Hörschl und Planck, ihr habt diesen Paket CAC, habt ihr denn jemals gesehen, dass da ein Fehler aufgetaucht ist? Sondern habe ich den Job gekriegt, das zu überprüfen, habe die Daten von zwei Jahren noch mal nachgeguckt, auch damit uns ja nichts durch die Lappen geht. Und wir haben das nicht gesehen und haben dann eine Mail geschickt. Vielen Dank, gute Frage, aber wir haben da noch nie ein Problem gesehen. Es gab es noch nie, dass ein Paket wirklich ein Fehler hatte.
Über diese lange Strecke?
Über diese lange Strecke, über diese vielen Jahre, über diese Millionen und Abermillionen von Paketen.
Also heißt das, dass sozusagen die Übertragung jedes Pakets funktioniert hat oder nur, dass jedes erfolgreich übertragende Paket dann auch die richtigen Daten da drin hatte?
Das mit dem CRC hat das Zweite, das Tolle an Hörschung Planck ist, dass wir im Wesentlichen eine unglaubliche Statistik haben. Wir haben bei Planck kein einziges Paket verloren. Was Quatsch ist, zu sagen, weil es wäre gut genug gewesen, wir hatten 98 Prozent. Also sozusagen dieses Extrem, sich wirklich um jedes einzelne Paket zu kümmern, war dann auch ein Sport, weil wir haben so viel Glück am Anfang gehabt und dann hat man sich natürlich nachher wirklich um jedes Paket gekümmert.
Ich meine, selbst wenn jetzt mal ein Paket nicht erfolgreich übertragen worden wäre, dann könnte man es ja gleich nochmal schicken.
Also wir haben uns da Mühe gegeben, bei Hörschel genau so. Nicht schlecht. Das ist unglaublich und dieser Paket CRC hilft natürlich dabei. Das bedeutet aber, dass sozusagen, wenn ein Instrument eine Beobachtung macht, diese Daten schreibt und diese Daten kommen wirklich 100% richtig am Boden an. Dafür ist dieses Paket CRC da. Jedenfalls eine Woche später nach dieser Mail kam dann bei Hörschel allerdings das Problem, da haben wir das erste Mal genau das gesehen.
Das ist eine Übertragung.
Dass von einem Instrument ein Paket kam und der Inhalt von dem Paket war nicht richtig. Und das hat uns, also erstens hat uns die Koinzidenz in der Zeit natürlich erst mal interessant gemacht. Es stellt sich natürlich nachher heraus, dass das überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun hat. Das war reiner Zufall. Und wir konnten es nicht verstehen. Also natürlich haben wir erst gedacht, das Instrument hat einen Fehler gemacht. Dann haben wir alle möglichen Tests gemacht mit Zusammenarbeit mit den Instrumentenbauern und so weiter. Haben uns nochmal die Daten alle angeguckt.
Also wir reden jetzt ja auch wirklich von einer Prüfsumme, die quasi das Instrument beim Wegschreiben in den Speicher anlegt.
Also Instrument…
Das hat nichts mit der Übertragung selber zu tun, sondern nur um die Korrektheit der erfassten Informationen schon on Board sicherzustellen, steht da nochmal eine Prüfsumme dabei. Damit man zu Not auch so ein kippendes Bit im Speicher, kann ja auch sein, dass der Speicher kaputt ist, etc., dass man sowas feststellen kann.
Genau, dass man sowas sieht und wir haben das gesehen und es war für uns unerklärlich, dann haben wir natürlich geforscht, es war nicht das Instrument. So, also der nächste Kandidat war der Hauptspeicher. Der Hauptspeicher ist aber super abgesichert, weil der hat zusätzlich nochmal eine eigene Zwischensumme und zwar in Hardware, nennt sich dann IDAC, und hat einen extra Mechanismus, der ständig über die Daten geht und immer kontrolliert, ob auch alles richtig ist. Und wenn sozusagen auf der Ebene ein Fehler hätte stattgefunden, also wenn da was sozusagen nachträglich im Hauptspeicher hätte sein können, ein Fehler passiert wäre, dann hätte eigentlich der Fehlerzähler einfach hochzählen müssen. Das hat er aber nicht.
Warum könnte man sich so sicher sein, dass das Instrument jetzt nicht die Prüfung falsch berechnet hat?
Das haben wir sozusagen aufgrund der Datenlage drumrum konnten wir nachweisen, dass das nicht sein kann. Also die haben alle möglichen Tests gemacht und zwar klar, das kann nicht sein und dann gab es ein treffendes Argument, weil nämlich das Paket gar nicht, dass die Daten, die wir bekommen haben, das kann das Instrument an der Stelle so gar nicht schreiben. Das gibt es gar nicht. Also dann hätte es multiple Fehler sein müssen. Davon geht man nicht aus. Also dann hätte das nicht nur an der Stelle sein können. Und was wir dann gemacht haben, wir haben natürlich Tests gemacht und haben aktiv vom Boden, also wir haben irgendwann festgestellt, es ist immer dieselbe Stelle im Hauptspeicher. Also da haben wir uns den Hauptspeicher angeguckt. Es ist immer dieselbe Stelle, wo dieser Fehler auftritt. Und das haben wir natürlich erforscht und mussten natürlich dann kurz die Mission ein bisschen anders betreiben. Haben das erforscht, haben da Daten hingeschickt, die kamen geändert runter. Daten, die wir hochgeschickt haben, kamen geändert runter und trotzdem ist dieser Zähler nicht hochgegangen. Das haben wir überhaupt nicht verstanden. Und dann haben wir diese Daten weggeschickt an die Industrie, haben gesagt, wir verstehen es nicht. Also entweder ist es wirklich was richtig kaputt am Hauptspeicher, sodass sogar noch nicht mal oder dieser Prozess, der das prüft, also wir haben alles Mögliche geglaubt. Also das Instrument war es nicht. Wir konnten, eigentlich haben wir das Vertrauen gehabt, dass der Hauptspeicher funktioniert, dass die Prozesse da funktionieren. Aber es musste ja irgendwas sein, deswegen haben wir gesagt, ja wir glauben nicht, dass es das ist, aber können Sie das nochmal prüfen? Könnte es das sein? Könnte es das sein? Haben wir in der Industrie zusammen gearbeitet und dann passiert das, was dann, aber es war dann schon ein Vierteljahr später, weil wir waren einfach, uns fiel nichts mehr ein. Das war wie, das darf nicht sein.
Es war aber auch wirklich jetzt nur ein einziges Datum, also nur eine einzige Erfassung, wo hat es sich dann ab dem Moment wiederholt?
Es waren 20 Speicherstellen, manche hatten immer den selben Wert, manche hatten einen anderen, aber viele davon hatten nie den Wert, den wir reingeschrieben haben. Wir haben es nicht verstanden, ich habe gedacht, ich kenne mich voll aus, ich habe einen Mikroprozessor entwickelt und habe alles Mögliche gemacht, es ging ewig hin und her, bis dann einer der Entwickler, auch ein ASIC-Entwickler von der Firma Ruag, gesagt hat, die Daten, die gehören da nicht hin, aber die sehen aus wie ein internes Protokoll von dem ASIC, das müsste an einer ganz anderen Stelle stehen, aber so sehen diese Daten aus, also einfach so vom Muster her, also der hat sozusagen hexadezimale Zahlen sehen können und er erkennt ein Muster da drin, das er kennt. Und dann haben wir weitergeforscht, wo, wieso speichert er das, wenn das so ist, wo speichert er das normalerweise ab? Ja, ganz unten im Speicher, nämlich von Null ab und wie legt er fest, wo er das hinschreibt? Natürlich in der Adresse Null gibt es die Daten, die da stehen, sind praktisch, wenn da steht Null, dann schreibt das bei Null ab, wenn da steht 1000, dann schreibt das im Speicherbereich 1000 ab. Und aus irgendeinem Grund stand da nicht Null, sondern ein anderer Wert und deswegen hat dieser ASIC seine Daten ständig, alle paar Sekunden, darüber geschrieben und da das ja ein richtiger Schreibprozess war, war das kein Fehler.
Verstehe, das heißt, ein anderes Bauteil hat die Daten quasi immer wieder überschrieben, aber damit waren ja dann eigentlich die Messdaten im Eimer.
An der Stelle waren sie dann im Eimer.
Und wie lange lief das so?
Das Tolle war, wir haben trotzdem so gut wie keine Pakete verloren, weil die Daten immer in zwei parallele Speicher gehen und wir das dann einfach immer vom anderen Speicher geholt haben.
Ah, jetzt wusste man sozusagen, auch der andere hat gestimmt, das heißt, an der Stelle hat einem die Prüfstimme dann aber auch wirklich geholfen. Geholfen.
Und insofern war es gut, dass wir das gemacht haben. Wir haben dann schlussendlich das Problem gelöst gehabt, haben diese Schweicheradresse überschrieben, alles war wieder gut. Es ging es natürlich nicht um Leben oder Tod, aber es ging einfach darum, zu verstehen, wie kann sowas sein. Und es hat in dem Fall einfach mal drei Monate gedauert, bis man rauskriegt, was es war.
Elektronik ist ja auch ein komplexes Thema. Also jetzt haben wir ja schon betont, Haschel und Planck sind so ein bisschen ans Ende gekommen. Das heißt, alle Messungen, die gemacht werden sollten, sind gemacht worden. Die sind jetzt noch technisch im Betrieb. Also die Maschinen wissen noch gar nichts davon, dass wir gar kein Interesse mehr an ihnen haben. Aber der Kühltreibstoff ist aus. Der ist verbraucht. Das heißt, die Dinger werden jetzt auch langsam warm.
Die werden warm. Das ist bei Planck ganz gut, weil man noch mal weitere Kalibrationsaufnahmen machen kann und sagen kann, wie verhalten sich die Instrumente, wenn sie wärmer sind. Das hilft ein bisschen besser, sie zu verstehen und dann besser die Daten zu kalibrieren. Bei Hörschel wird definitiv keine Science mehr gemacht. Was wir ein bisschen machen, jetzt haben wir schon diese tollen Instrumente da draußen, machen sogenannte technische Tests. Also Dinge, die nicht gefährlich sind, weil wir wollen sicherstellen, dass wir sie wirklich weggeschoben bekommen. Also alles Gefährliche machen wir nicht, aber die Dinge, die nicht gefährlich sind, aber die interessant sind, also zum Beispiel haben wir für Hörschel ja ein riesen Manöver geflogen, um eben vom L2 weiter rauszukommen und dieses Manöver war so lange, die...
Also er ist jetzt auch schon nicht mehr an seinem ursprünglichen Einsatzort.
Nein, Hörschel ist nicht mehr am L2, ist sozusagen schon lange auf dem Weg nach draußen und dieses Manöver war so groß, dass jetzt die Industrie freut und sagt, so ein Manöver wurde mit diesen Düsen noch nie geflogen und diese ganzen Daten, wie heiß das wird und so weiter, das ist praktisch wie Forschung, natürlich auf einer anderen Ebene.
Weil die Düsen immer nur für Korrekturen ausgelegt sind und in diesem Fall mal wirklich für eine…
Naja, die waren schon auch ausgelegt, um in den L2 zu fliegen und die Korrekturen, also die waren schon richtige Größe, also schon richtige größere Düsen, um solche Delta Vs zu fliegen, aber so ein großes Delta V war für die nicht vorgesehen. Und es war schon relativ klar, dass das wohl geht, aber klar ist die Industrie natürlich garantiert, was, wo sie sicher ist, dass sie garantieren kann und sie kann halt jetzt mit diesen Daten dieselben Düsen einfach, hat ein größeres Portfolio, also da profitieren auch zukünftige Missionen davon. Also es gibt zum Glück, also die ESA macht die Astronomie-Missionen Weg der Wissenschaft, das ist das Kerngeschäft. Das heißt, das Kerngeschäft sind die wissenschaftlichen Daten, die wir dann an die Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen liefern. Das ist das, was wir machen und was wir bei der ESOC machen, ist, wir betreiben die Satelliten so gut, wie wir es nur irgen können, damit die Daten, die dann die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler bekommen, so gut wie möglich sind. Aber jetzt kriegen wir noch einen Bonus obendrauf. Jetzt kriegen wir den Bonus, wir können diese Triebwerke sozusagen, haben wir betrieben wie sie noch nie betrieben wurden und sie haben funktioniert. Und solche Tests werden, also solche Dinge passieren gerade, es ist eher so Technologietests, die wir machen und die machen auch Sinn und das ist eh in Betrieb, also warum nicht für sowas nutzen?
Ja genau, jetzt kann man es nochmal so richtig, so ein bisschen so.
Ja es gab tolle Ideen, was man noch machen kann, denen wir widersprochen haben, weil sozusagen dann hätte es ein Risiko bedeutet, können wir wirklich, darf sicherstellen, dass dann Hörschel und Planck wirklich am Ende passiviert sind.
Und was wurde da gedacht?
Zum Beispiel die Lage-Regelung anders zu programmieren, da gibt es gute neue Ideen, wie man das machen kann, da hätte man aber das neu, also sein neues Programm entwickeln und testen müssen und uploaden und dann, wenn das dann nicht geklappt hätte, was hätte man dann gemacht? Also klar es gibt immer einen Weg zurück, aber solche Dinge zum Beispiel waren uns zu risikoreich.
Aber ist denn jetzt der Satellit, also Herschel, jetzt schon da, wo er verbleiben soll?
Ne, ist auf dem Weg dorthin. Und es gibt dann sozusagen, und praktisch einfach, also kamen sie einfach rausgeschossen, aber natürlich in eine bestimmte gute Art und Weise rausgeschossen und es ist so, dass wir zwei wichtige Dinge noch machen, bevor wir ihn wirklich abschalten. Was heißt abschalten? Also das eine ist, wir wollen wirklich die Tanks leeren. Das heißt, wir machen noch ein Manöver am Schluss, wo wir sagen, wir machen ein großes Manöver und dann ist es uns egal, wann sozusagen das Hydrazin alle ist, egal, es ist gleich alle oder nach 20 Minuten, wir lernen praktisch die Hydrazintanks, indem wir noch ein großes Manöver fliegen. Und das ist so ausgerechnet, egal wann es leer ist, es ist immer das richtige Manöver. Also das kann kurz oder lang sein, weil wir sowieso schon richtig sind und wir machen, dass es alles so geschickt von der Flugdynamik berechnet, dass es dann keinen Fehler gibt, sondern dann irgendwann ist es aus und dann ist es gut. Und das ist das eine Wichtige. Das zweite Wichtige, was wir machen, was man vermeiden will, ist, dass irgendwann irgendein Satellit irgendwo noch rumfunkt, weil die Funkfrequenzen sind alle rar und wir wollen sicherstellen, dass Hörschel und Planck nie wieder funken. So und das ist gar nicht so leicht, denn das ganze Ding ist ja gebaut worden, das ist im schlimmsten aller Fälle, wenn es noch irgendwie es schafft, seine Solarpanels in die Sonne zu drehen, dass es dann natürlich sagt, hallo Erde, hier bin ich, ich hab's wieder hingekriegt, rede mit mir. Das heißt, Hörschel und Planck sind so gebaut und wie alle anderen Satelliten auch, die gehen in den Sun Acquisition Mode, also Sonne ist ja wichtig, braucht Strom, wenn sie keinen Kontakt haben, dann sagen sie erst mal Hauptsache Strom, ab einem gewissen Level von Fehlern, wenn der groß genug ist, sagt er, es ist mir alles egal, das kümmere ich mich nur noch um das, was wirklich wesentlich ist. Ich brauche A, Strom, also Solarpanel in die Sonne. B, ich brauche Bodenkontakt, weil die müssen ja mal rauskriegen, was los ist. Und der ganze Rest, mach mal langsam. Also nichts Komplexes, nichts, wir machen es ganz, wir beschränken uns auf die Wesentliche. Und das ist so automatisiert und hart verdrahtet, dass wir ein halbes Jahr gebraucht haben, um eine Idee zu kriegen, wie können wir dann dieses Funkgerät ausstellen? Weil es gibt nämlich den Fall, klar können wir es einfach per Kommando ausstellen, nur es gibt den Fall, wenn sozusagen die Solarpanel aufgrund von Drift irgendwie rausgehen, dass Strom komplett weg ist und dann startet ja, irgendwann kommt wieder Strom und dann ist es einfach so gebaut, sobald Strom geht, fängt alles wieder an zu leben. Also die wichtigen Sachen.
Ein Auto-Reboot sozusagen, weil ich weiß gar nicht, was vorher war, überhaupt vergessen, dass er eigentlich ausgeschaltet sein soll, fängt wieder bei Null an und denkt, ja, ich bin hier, wo seid ihr denn?
Genau und das erste, was er macht, Solarpanel in die Sonne und das zweite ist, Funkgerät an und sagen, hier, ich will mit dir da.
Was können wir machen, Solarpaneele absprengen?
Ja, also wir haben tausend Ideen gehabt und dann immer, nee, das geht das nicht wegen diesem Automatismus, also wir haben lange rumgemacht und dann, wir haben ihn am Ende ausgetrickst und zwar ist es so, dass eine ganze Kette von Dingen passieren müssen, bei Hörschl und Planck übrigens identisch, bis diese Funkgeräte angeschaltet werden. Die werden nacheinander eingeschaltet und da kann man von etwa acht oder neun Sachen, die passieren müssen, sind alle hart verdrahtet, da konnten wir nichts machen. Es gibt nur am Schluss ein Software-Kommando, das wird dann irgendwann startet der Hauptrechner und der Hauptrechner guckt sich das alles an, alles gut und schickt am Ende ein Kommando und sagt so, jetzt noch ein bestimmtes Bauteil vom Funkgerät an und dann ist es an. Und wir konnten nicht verhindern, dass dieses Kommando geschickt wird, das geht auch nicht. Aber was wir gemacht haben am Ende war folgendes, es gibt ein extra Kommando für an und es gibt ein extra Kommando für aus und wir haben in der Software nicht die Software geändert, sondern haben gesagt, immer wenn du ein An-Kommando schicken willst, haben wir die ganzen Kommandos in der Software in Aus-Kommandos geändert. Das heißt, die Software macht am Schluss das An-Kommando, denkt, dass es das macht, aber eigentlich ist es ein Aus-Kommando, es war ja eh aus und so haben wir es am Schluss geschafft.
Das heißt, man hat den Fall gar nicht bedacht am Anfang?
Ne, man baut und das ist auch richtig so, man baut ein Satellit so, dass der im schlimmsten aller Fälle weitergeläuft. Man baut nicht, also ich habe es schon gehört, ich kenne aber jetzt persönlich keine Mission, aber das macht schon Sinn, also man macht sich unheimlich viel Mühe, da wird auch viel Geld und da haben ja Hunderte von Ingenieuren haben darüber nachgedacht und man erfindet natürlich das Rad nicht jedes Mal neu, aber haben trotzdem darüber nachgedacht, wie muss man das machen, dass wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt, dass die Mission wieder mit uns in Kontakt geht, dass sie Strom hat, dass wir Probleme lösen können. Und wenn man dann immer noch mitdenkt, wir wollen es irgendwann mal abschalten, das geht nicht, weil man muss das ja auch alles testen und das ist ein zusätzlicher Fehler. Also das ist nicht von Anfang an design worden, sondern das haben wir am Schluss, haben wir uns zusammengesetzt und dann reden wir miteinander und verwirft die Idee und so weiter, aber das war auch anstrengend, weil die ganze Zeit möchten wir immer retten und möchten immer dafür sorgen, dass die Missionen stabil laufen und auf einmal muss man sich hinsetzen und dieses Ding zerstören. Das hat für mich eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich überhaupt in den Denkmodus gehen konnte. Also wie gegen meinen Satelliten und nicht für meinen Satelliten.
Das war ja jetzt Herrschel, im Prinzip ist das ja auch der Abschluss, gehört ja zu beiden.
Naja, also das haben wir entwickelt für Planck und das war so gut, dass Herrschel gesagt hat, wir machen genau dasselbe.
Planck ist aber noch da, wo er zuletzt im Einsatz war.
Immer noch im L2.
Und weiß selbst noch nichts davon, dass man ihn eigentlich gar nicht mehr interessiert. Und was kann man mit dem jetzt noch machen?
Naja, also was wir jetzt noch machen, das Low-Frequency-Instrument, das funktioniert auch noch ohne diese Super-Duper-Kühlung, natürlich nicht mehr so gut, hat höheres thermisches Rauschen und es wird immer noch ein Scan gemacht und der wird für Kalibration benutzt und der wird, zum besseren Verständnis natürlich, das Instrument auch benutzt und sozusagen, das sind jetzt nicht mehr große Welten, also wir können nicht die Daten jetzt die Qualität verdoppeln oder so, es geht jetzt um Prozentbereiche. Aber es ist eben ein so wichtiges Forschungsfeld, dass selbst ein paar Prozent, die wir jetzt noch rauskitzeln können, auch noch was wert sind.
Und man gewinnt aber auch so ein bisschen Informationen darüber, wie es denn gewesen wäre, wenn man jetzt nicht so weit runtergekühlt hätte.
Genau, also das ist zwar nie das Ziel gewesen, aber da wir das jetzt sozusagen umsonst kriegen, ist das natürlich klasse, dass man jetzt den Detektor auch nochmal versteht, wie er, wenn es nicht geklappt hätte mit der Kühlung.
Aber das ist ja auch so eine Materialprüfung, die sich jetzt, ich frage mich sowieso, wie diese Kühlung hat entwickelt werden können, weil die auf der Erde ja so wahrscheinlich gar nicht getestet werden konnte.
Ein Stück weit natürlich, also es ist auch im Labor auf der Erde nicht so leicht, diese Kühlungen so zu bauen, also das können natürlich manche, aber...
Ja, man ist halt nicht so weit weg von der Erde, sondern sie ist halt direkt unter einem Heim und brütet die ganze Zeit so vor sich hin hier, unser heißer Klotz. Der aktuelle Sommer gibt am 2. Rande nicht so das Gefühl, als könnte diese Erde große Satellitmissionen beeinflussen, aber so ist es nun mal. So, jetzt ist ja die Mission beendet, wie du schon gesagt hast, es wurde ja jetzt auch groß bereits verkündet, dass dem so ist und es wurden ja auch schon erste Ergebnisse vorgestellt. Was meint man denn jetzt gelernt zu haben? Also es gibt ja dieses schöne Ellipsoid, dieses Bild, was da als Kernergebnis mit herausgeworfen wurde. Wenn man sich das jetzt so anschaut, dann ist man so als Laie, wundert man sich so ein bisschen. Was steckt denn da jetzt drin?
Naja, also was man bisher sozusagen schon entwickelt hat und gesehen hat, man hat ja praktisch nur einen Bruchteil der Daten. Also ich sag mal, über einen Daumen viertel der Daten hat man jetzt analysiert. Das geht also noch viel besser. Und ich habe vorher schon gesagt, man muss von dem ganzen Vordergrund rausrechnen, auch das geht alles noch besser. Also ich glaube, die große Ära der Planck-Wissenschaft, die steht unmittelbar bevor und das kann in einem halben Jahr an dem Jahr sein oder so, also wo dann sozusagen die großen Sachen kommen könnten, theoretisch. Aber das ist eine persönliche Meinung, eins, was ich so raushöre ist, es gibt ja in dem Kosmologie-Modell nach dem Urknall diese Inflation, die bei 10 auf minus 50 Sekunden anfängt, bei 10 auf minus 30 aufhört, wo sich das Universum schneller ausgedehnt hat als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Das geht, ohne dass man die Relativitätstheorie verletzt, weil da dürfen nur Lichtstrahlen oder sowas nicht schneller sein, aber der Raum selber darf sich natürlich schon schneller ausdehnen. Und das ist möglich und das hat man gebraucht, diese Inflation.
Tut er das nicht jetzt auch? Also dehnt sich das Universum nicht jetzt auch?
Ja, es kann sein, dass das physikalisch miteinander zu tun hat, aber darüber ist man sich auch nicht sicher. Aber diese Inflation hat man gebraucht in den Kosmologie-Modellen unter anderem, deswegen, weil eben diese kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung so überall dieselbe Temperatur hat. Denn nur dann kann die so gleich sein, wenn sich das irgendwie nach und nach ausgedehnt hätte und so weiter, dann wäre das eine heiß und das andere... Also diese unterschiedlichen Mini-Temperaturen sind ja Energien und da, wo es heißer war, war mehr Masse und da, wo es kühler ist, da war weniger. Und das hätte aber viel größere Unterschiede machen müssen. Und die Inflation war eine tolle Theorie, um diese Gleichheit zu erklären. Heutzutage ist es aber so, das hat Roger Penrose zum Beispiel publiziert, aber auch andere, dass, wenn man schon an Inflation glaubt, dann sind die Parameter für diese spezielle Inflation, die sogenannte schlechte Inflation, die sind so am Rand von den Parameterwerten, das ist so richtig, wie man hat eine Messung und trickst eine Theorie hin, dass man dann zu diesem Ergebnis kommt. Das ist schon seit ein paar Jahren umstritten. Aber trotzdem ist es das kanonische Modell, wo alle erst mal dran glauben, weil es macht Sinn, aber es gibt schon lange Kritik daran. Und ich kann mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass mit den Planck-Daten, der Güte der Planck-Daten, wenn man dann auch noch den Rest nicht nur die Gesamtheit der Daten anschaut, sondern auch, da gibt es auch noch was, wo man dann sozusagen die Polarisation in diesen Daten noch sehen kann. Wenn man das alles zusammen ankommt, glaube ich, dass es vielleicht zu einem Ergebnis kommen könnte, dass man sagt, ja, also Inflation, das kann man nicht ausschließen, aber es wird immer unwahrscheinlicher, dass das die Erklärung ist. Es ist viel wahrscheinlicher, dass es vielleicht was anderes ist, was normaleres, was mit normaler Physikinflation ist, etwas, was ein bisschen außerhalb der normalen Physik ist. Das passt mit den vier Grundkräften nicht zusammen, dass wir das auch mit normaler Physik hinkriegen. Und das weiß ich nicht, ich habe die Daten nicht gesehen, aber das ist das, was ich so rieche. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Eine andere publizierte Schlussfolgerung aus diesen Beobachtungen war ja, dass man gerade auch noch mal diesen Anteil von normaler Materie versus dunkler Materie anhand dieser Beobachtungen hat neu bestimmen können. Warum konnte man das ausgerechnet über diese Beobachtungen machen?
Also es gibt so eine sogenannte kritische Dichte. Und diese kritische Energiedichte, die muss nachher, nachher muss sozusagen, wie die komponiert ist, muss nachher eins ergeben. Und aufgrund dessen, wie diese Strukturen, also es hat was mit den Abstände zwischen gleichen Temperaturen misst, also dass man sozusagen Skalen messen kann in diesem Muster. Und daraus kann man so eine Komponente entwickeln. Und dann muss man, dann kann man daraus zurückschließen, wie diese Verteilung zwischen baryonischer Materie, das ist das, was wir kennen, dunkler Materie und dunkler Energie sein muss, damit man genau zu einem Universum kommt, das wir heute sehen und das auch sozusagen zusammenpasst mit dem, also muss alles zusammenpassen, also die Gleichheit der Temperatur im kosmischen Mikrowellenhintergrund, die minimalen Unterschiede, die Strukturgrößen da drauf und das heutige Universum, also sozusagen wie viel Galaxien, wie sind die verklumpt, wie viel Platz ist dazwischen, wie alt ist das alles, das hängt alles zusammen und diese ganzen Modellparameter von der Kosmologie, da kann man an vielen, kann man sozusagen noch mal ein paar Kommastellen genauer sehen, Wir sehen jetzt mit den Daten von Planck. Und deswegen kann man andere Parameter, die damit zu tun haben, auch neu bestimmen und genauer bestimmen.
Aber so die erste Feststellung ging jetzt in meiner Wahrnehmung so eher in die Richtung mit, wir haben bestätigen können, was wir vermutet haben. Wir haben zwar ein paar Zahlen anders hinter der Kommastelle, als das vielleicht vorher war oder vielleicht auch vor der Kommastelle. Aber im Wesentlichen bestätigt Planck auch das bisher gewonnene Weltbild. Also die These des Urknalls als solche lässt sich ein weiteres Mal noch weiter zuzimmern. Was kann man sich denn an langfristigen Erkenntnissen jetzt noch versprechen? Also Erkenntnis ist natürlich schwierig, aber in welche Bereiche wird denn das jetzt noch hin abgeklopft?
Also das eine habe ich schon genannt. Also ich glaube, dieses Thema Inflation kann noch spannend werden, kann auch sein, das wird total bestätigt. Aber ich glaube, dass darum geht es einfach.
Aber das ist so ein Ding, gut, aber das ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Detail im Ablauf, ja?
Ja, schon ein wesentliches Detail. Das zweite haben wir auch schon angesprochen, wie ist das Universum komponiert, was sind die Anteile eben. Und ja, auch diese sozusagen, es ist schon wirklich so, diese Struktur, wo ist da sozusagen heiße und kälter, hat was mit der Struktur zu tun, wo sind jetzt Galaxienhaufen und wo sind keine und auch darüber sozusagen die weit entfernten Galaxien, die kann man ja auch zunehmend immer besser sehen, weil man auch vom Boden aus sozusagen immer bessere Teleskope bauen kann und so weiter. Und diese, also auch da lernt man einfach was wieder über die Struktur und da das jetzt noch genauer ist und noch feiner, kann man also all diese Dinge, also ist ja nicht so, also ich kenne von Planck nichts, wo man jetzt wesentlich was Neues gesehen hat, was man noch nie gesehen hat, also davon weiß ich nicht.
Aber man hat ja im Prinzip ein besseres Vergleichsmaterial, weil man eigentlich zu jedem Flecken des Universums, zu dem man hinschauen kann, auch jetzt immer noch so ein Abbild der Urvergangenheit noch mit dazu hat und das in Relation setzen kann. Hier ist irgendwie viel los, da Wimmels vor Galaxienhaufen.
Das ist jetzt Kosmologie und was man aber schon auch noch gemacht hat, waren zusätzliche Sachen. Also da gibt es diesen unaussprechlichen Effekt, Zeldanyov, irgendwas.
Immer die Russen definieren immer diese krassen Begriffe.
Ja, da hat man ja zum Beispiel auch mit XMM zusammengearbeitet, da hat man also gesehen, ah, da gibt es sowas, da gibt es diesen Effekt. Da werden, dass es praktisch wie ein Inversor kommt. Also da werden sozusagen, da kommt mehr Energie von einer Stelle, als da sein müsste. Da hat man mit XMM hingeguckt und hat gesehen, ah ja, da ist eine Galaxie. Es haben sogar mehrere Galaxien und so weiter. Und XMM könnte ja nie in alle Richtungen gucken, weil es wie eine Stecknadel guckt. Und da war praktisch Planck ein Pfadfinder für guckt mal dahin. Das ist total interessant.
Das ist so eine Art Schatzkarte, wo man sagen kann, hier B-Dragons. Das haben wir mehrmals gemacht.
Solche Sachen hat Planck natürlich gesehen. Das war auch vorgesehen. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt nicht Kosmologie, sondern da geht es einfach um Galaxien und Galaxienhaufen. So etwas hat Planck natürlich auch gemacht. Und diese Daten sind ja jetzt nicht weg. Man kann ja diese Daten auch in Ruhe noch angucken und wird weitere Stellen finden und kann wieder sagen, hey, das war zwar nicht so, wir mussten noch länger dran arbeiten, aber hier haben wir noch mal eine Stelle gefunden. Das kann noch ein paar Jahre, immer wieder wird es Dinge geben, die man in den Planck-Daten sieht, weil die eben auch wirklich so eine hohe Qualität haben, dass man auch noch lange damit rechnen kann, um noch mehr rauszuziehen und noch mehr rauszuziehen und noch mehr Vordergrund weg und so weiter. Dass man dann wahrscheinlich immer wieder noch Dinge findet, wo man sagt, jetzt gucken wir nochmal mit XMM drauf oder mit Integral. Und das ist sozusagen was zweites, was da auch passiert ist. Das ist natürlich lustig, weil das ist ja Vordergrund. Das ist ja das, was man eigentlich gar nicht haben will. Aber um den Vordergrund abzuziehen, muss man ihn verstehen. Und da hat wiederum XMM geholfen. Wenn man das mit XMM genau anguckt, kann man das genau verstehen, weiß genau, was das für eine Strahlung ist und kann die noch besser von der Planckkarte abziehen und wird der Hintergrund wieder besser. Also man kann so richtig gewinnen.
Verstehe, das ergänzt sich alles gegenseitig. Ja, Nicolai, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es aber auch hier gebaut, das Planck-Gebilde abgebildet, sozusagen die Hintergrundstrahlung dieses Projektes ausreichend vermessen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es, die 55. Ausgabe. Wir hören uns bald wieder. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.